SENATE BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE WILL COME TO
ORDER- AND ALL GO THROUGH OUR
INSTRUCTIONS GOOD MORNING. IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERED NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES
WE MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS IN HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING TODAY IN THE CAPITAL.
ARE ALL THE SENATORS WILL BE
PRESENT SENATOR MAN IS WITH ME
NOW SENATOR OTRO BOGUS EXPECTED
MOMENTARILY. OF THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. FOR OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID ENDED ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASKED
THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU RAISE YOUR
USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE
IN THE PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR. ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING. OUR REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN I SEE IT'S UP THERE NOW.
A TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. 877-226-8163. 877-226-8163 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. 736-283-3736
TWO EIGHT THREE THREE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
USE THE TELECONFERENCE ISTOM AND
HOW IT WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE AND OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
. WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
. PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LONG NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LONG
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE ON
MUTED AND YOU'RE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM
YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO
BE DONE TODAY NO LATER. THAN
ELEVEN TWENTY OR ELEVEN TWENTY
FIVE AND NORMALLY WILL ALLOW
EVERYBODY A MINUTES BUT WE'LL
WAIT AND SEE WHERE WE ARE AT AT
THAT TIME TO MAKE SURE. THAT WE
HAVE AS MANY PEOPLE THAT CAN
PARTICIPATE. EITHER IN PERSON
TESTIMONY IN THIS ROOM. THE WAR
BY A TELECONFERENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. IN TODAY'S
HEARING. WHICH IS THE EIGHTH OF
NINE HEARINGS AND TOMORROW WILL
BE THE NINTH. ARE WE WILL REVIEW
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS AROUND
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN AND
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM. AND IN OUR FIRST PANEL
WHICH WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO.
ARE UNDER THE EXPANSION OF
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN WHICH
PEOPLE REFER TO AS T. K. SO YOU
CAN GET USED TO THE ACRONYM
BEFORE IT HAPPENS. ARE ON THE
FIRST PANEL WE WILL HAVE WIENER
GRANT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
EDGAR CABRAL THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND SERRA NOVEL
MORGAN THE DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT
FOR OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL BRANCH
. ARE IN THE FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION AND THEN WE HAVE A
SECOND PANEL ON THIS ITEM. WHICH
WILL BE ON LOCAL PERSPECTIVES
AND WILL HAVE REBEKAH ANDRADE
THE SUPERINTENDENT OF THE
SALINAS CITY ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
DISTRICT CANDY TAYLOR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES OF THE CYBER SCHOOL
DISTRICT. AND JENNIFER HICKS
ASSISTANT SUPERINTENDENT OF
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES FOR THE
PLASTER COUNTY OF OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND THEY OPERATE THE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM IN IN THAT
COUNTY. AND I THINK PROCESS WISE
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO TODAY IS
WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF ALL ISSUES. AND WE'LL GO
THROUGH PANEL ONE AND THEN WE'LL
GO TO PANEL TO BEFORE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS SO THAT WE HAVE THE
BENEFIT. OF THE-
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL IN THE
DESCRIPTION AND ANALYSIS AND
THEN LOCAL PERSPECTIVES AND WE
CAN HAVE ALL THAT BEFORE WE
START TO HAVE QUESTIONS OR
CONVERSATION. SO WITH THAT.
REMOVED PANEL NUMBER ONE AND
WILL GO ON THE ORDER I MENTIONED
SO THE FIRST ONE IS WHEN A GRANT
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND A WELCOME TO THE SUB
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU A GOOD
MORNING SHARON MEMBERS LENA
GRANT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
. THE PRESENTING YOU WITH A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN EXPANSION AS WELL
AS THE TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
EXT- PROPOSAL FOR THE ADULT TO
STUDENT RATIO REDUCTION PROPOSAL
. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
A REVENGE OF THE TEST ONE
PERCENTAGE PROP UP PERCENTAGE OF
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT. TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE ESTIMATED
INCREASED COST OF ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS SERVED IN TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN AS A RESULT. OF THE
EXPANSION APPROVED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT FOR TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE. THIS EXPANSION
IS CURRENTLY ESTIMATED AT SIX
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE MILLION.
AS A REMINDER THE EXPANSION
REFLECTS THE OPENING T. K.
FOURTEEN TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN TO ALL CHILDREN
TURNING FIVE BETWEEN SEPTEMBER
SECOND AND FEBRUARY SECOND
RATHER THAN. THE TIMBER SECOND
AND DECEMBER SECOND I BEGINNING
WITH THE TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
SCHOOL YEAR. WHILE NOT
CONSTITUTIONALLY REQUIRED THIS
PROPOSAL IS CONSISTENT WITH PAST
PRACTICE TO ADJUST THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
CALCULATION TO ACCOUNT FOR THE
MOVEMENT- AND FUNDING OF
PROGRAMS WITHIN OR OUTSIDE OF
THE GUARANTEE RELATIVE TO EIGHTY
SIX EIGHTY SEVEN LEVELS. IN
ADDITION TO THE INCREASED LCF
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA FUNDING PROVIDED FOR
EXPANDING TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ALSO PROPOSES A SEPARATE
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THREE
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT FOR
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. THE
HELP OF LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES REDUCE ADULT TO STUDENT
RATIOS TWO ONE TO TWELVE THIRTY
K. CLASSROOM PURSUANT TO STATUTE
. AND THIS CONCLUDES MY BRIEF
PRESENTATION OF MY COLLEAGUE
CHRIS FERGUSON IS ALSO ON THE
LINE AND WE ARE HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A NOW
WILL MOVE TO EDGAR CABRAL FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WELCOME TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
NUMBERS UNDER CONTROL WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AND WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
COMMENTS HERE I THINK I'M THE
BOTH OF THESE PROPOSALS ARE THE
EXPANSION OF TRADITIONAL CAN ARM
AND ASSOCIATED WITH BENCHING.
AND THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
STAFFING RATIOS ARE PART OF THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
AGREEMENT WITH THE LEGISLATURE-
BUT CONTINUE TO REVIEW THE
PROPOSALS BUT IN TERMS OF THE-
ESTIMATES OF THE- OF THE-
REPENTING A PROBLEM THE EIGHT.
MUNICIPAL FOREVER STOPPING OUR
OF ALIGNED WITH WHAT WE HAD
EXPECTED- WHEN THE AGREEMENT WAS
MADE AND- LAST YEAR- I'M SORRY
BUT I'M HAPPIER AFTER. YOU MIGHT
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
NOW WE MOVE ON TO THE SERRANO
MORGAN DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT FOR
OPPORTUNITIES. AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION. THE IT MORNING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THEIR NUMBER
MORE ON THE- OF STATE SUPER. OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION AND- WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THAT AND- YOU
CAN LAST YEAR YOU NEED PRE. YOU
CAN WITH THIS YEAR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET INVESTMENT THE SUPPORT
THE FIRST YEAR OF TAKING
EXPANSION AND REDUCE THE DEL
CHILD RATIOS IN T. PAY. THE
SUPPORT THIS INVESTMENT IN
DECEMBER CDP RELEASED AN INTENSE
LIFE FOR LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES OR ELEAZAR TO USE IN
THEIR UNIVERSAL PRE KINDERGARTEN
FOR U. K. PLANNING. THIS
TEMPLATE COVERS VISION AND
COHERENT COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
AND PARTNERSHIPS WORKFORCE
RECRUITMENT PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING CURRICULUM INSTRUCTION
AND ASSESSMENT AND FACILITY
SERVICES IN OPERATION AS YOU CAN
TELL THERE'S A LOT BEHIND. THE
NINETEEN YEAR. EARLIER THIS
MONTH WE ALSO BELIEVE NINETY
FIVE PAGES OF GUIDANCE THIS
ELEAZAR AS THEY WORK ON
DEVELOPING THEIR PLANS FOR
EXPANDING THE U. K. WHICH ARE
DUE TO THEIR LOCAL GOVERNING
BOARDS OR BODIES FOR
CONSIDERATION JUNE THIRTIETH OF
THIS YEAR. THIS CD PLANS TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE IN
THE COMING MONTHS. TO DEVELOP
BOTH THE TEMPLATE AND THE
GUIDANCE IS THE FOR ELEAZAR IN
THEIR YOU CAME. NT SOME PLANNING
THE CDC DEVELOPED A
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS TO ENGAGE
WITH REPRESENTATIVES FROM
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION. COUNTY
PARTNERS AND LOCAL IMPLEMENTERS.
THIS PROCESS HEALTH EXPEDIENCY
ARE AT THE TOP PLATE AND COMFY
DIED IN HIS RESPONSES. TO ME.
AND THAT EXCEPT FOR IT
IMPLEMENTORS TO LEVERAGE
EXISTING RESOURCES AND CREATE
NEW PARTNERSHIPS. WITH ALSO
HOSTED MULTIPLE WEBINARS WITH
OVER A THOUSAND BECAUSE- I'M- TO
UNDERSTAND THAT PLANNING
TEMPLATE WORKFORCE NEEDS AND
ADDRESS PRESCHOOL OR PRE
KINDERGARTEN TO THIRD GRADE
ALIGNMENT. AND HOW TO BETTER
WORK AND LEVERAGE THEIR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS. AS PART OF.
THE U. K. PROVIDES A- INCREDIBLE
OFFER. TO THINK. IF TO WE ARE SO
AS THE STATE. AS WE LOOK AT THE
DATA FOR TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
THERE WERE OVER A MILLION THREE
AND FOUR YEAR OLD CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE SPACES IN OUR STATE TO SERVE
AS CHILDREN BETWEEN OUR
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM FOR C. S. B. P. T. K.
AND HEAD START AND OTHER STATE
AND CHILD CARE SUBSIDIES THAT
ARE ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. THERE WERE ONLY THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN IF THIS.
AND SOMETIMES CHILDREN ARE
ENROLLED WITH MULTIPLE FUNDING
SOURCES. THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
CHILDREN SIR BETWEEN ARE
SUBSIDIZED BRIEFCASE SYSTEM AND
SUCH A CHILD CARE WAS LESS THAN
THAT AMOUNT. THIS MEANS THAT
LESS THAN ONE THIRD OF THREE AND
FOUR YEAR OLD CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA ACCESS TO PUBLIC PRE
K. PROCESS I FELT. ACTUALLY
HELPED. HAS JUST UNDER EIGHT
HUNDRED LATE INTO FOR CHILDREN
BIRTH TO AGE TWELVE OVERALL.
THEY'RE NOT ALL UNDER AGE NEED
NOT BRING CARE. IS SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT DO YOU. CALIFORNIA LACKS
THE CAPACITY TO MEET CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES. EVEN WHEN WE LOOK
AT OUR CALIFORNIA'S DECREASE THE
PROGRAM AND WHERE FAMILIES ARE
SERVED WE KNOW THAT OUT AS- WE
HAD ONLY ABOUT FORTY THOUSAND
THREE YEAR OLD. OUT OF OVER
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND ELIGIBLE
THREE YEAR OLDS. THAT MEANS WE
SENT LESS THAN 13% OF OUR
ELIGIBLE THREE YEAR OLD IN OUR
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM. THIS
REPRESENTS ABOUT 8% OF ALL THREE
WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO DURING
. FIRST FOUR EURO FOR STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM SERVE NEARLY A
HUNDRED KIDS OUT. THERE ABOUT
32% OF ELIGIBLE FOR EUROPE.
KNOWING THIS WE LOOK FORWARD S.
T. K. WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE UP
MORE AND MORE OF OUR FOUR YEAR
OLD. EMAILS THAT THOSE ELIGIBLE
SPACES RIGHT NOW SERVING FOUR
YEAR OLDS AND SAFETY FROM MEANS
THAT WE WOULD STILL NEED TWICE
THE NUMBER OF SLOTS TO EXPRESS
OUR THREE YEAR OLD. AND MOVING
FORWARD. MAYBE K. TRULY PROVIDES
AND OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL FOUR
YEAR OLD CHILDREN HAVE ACCESS TO
HIGH QUALITY PRE K. THE YEAR
BEFORE KINDERGARTEN. AND
POTENTIALLY EVEN THIRTEEN OLD
GIRL SMS THE PROPOSAL FROM. THE
FIRST HAND WE TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR U. K. EXPANSION IS
SUPPORTING THE MAKES THE LIBERTY
SYSTEM AND CREATING NEXT
HOSPITAL WHERE ASK EVERYONE TO
THAT THIS IS NOT JUST ON THANK
BUT ON THE BROADER.
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SUPPORT OF
THEM AND KNOWING THAT IT'S
CRITICAL FOR A TEACHER PAY BLANK
INSTABILITY TO MOVE FOR IT AS
PART OF THE EFFORT TO ENSURE THE
ALLEY EIGHT HAVE WHAT THEY NEED. TO ADDRESS. ONE NOT PARTY HERE
TODAY WE WOULD URGE THE LEAD.
NAY MINISTRY. KEEP IN MIND THAT
YOU CAN PAY THIS WITHIN THAT
LARGER COLLECTION OF PROFOUND.
AND THAT MAYBE FORWARD WE HAVE
TO ADDRESS THEM THE ISSUE OF
CONCERN THAT YOU'LL PROBABLY
HEAR. IN THE NEXT. WHEN SEE
WE'VE HEARD FROM OUR STATE
PRESCHOOL IS THAT THE LACK OF
ALIGNMENT IN RE STRUCTURES
ACROSS THE PROGRAM. AT THE
CENTER. ON EACH OVER HER. THREE
RIGHT ARE YOU IN THIS YEARS BE
ABLE PASS ACCOMPLISHMENT AND
THAT THERE SOMETHING ABOUT. WE
ALSO HEAR THAT THERE ISN'T AN
STRUCTURAL CHANGES I THINK THIS
BILL FROM. THAT WITH. YES.
THIRTY PARTNER WITH ONLY A AND
REALLY SUPPORT EACH TREATED YOU
EXPANSION. THE MAKING OUR STATE
IS THE PROGRAM BECAUSE NOW
ELEAZAR ALL THREE FOUR YEAR OLD
TOLD. INCREASE FIFTIETH
REIMBURSEMENT RATE RIGHT HIGHER
COMPENSATION OKAY TEACHERS.
REDUCE OR ELIMINATING THE
PAYMENT HE. DEVELOPMENT WE'LL BE
RELEASING OUR FEE FOR THAT
SHORTLY BUT WE HAD ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED AND NINETY FOUR ELIGIBLE
LETTERS OF INTENT FOR THAT
HUNDRED MILLION ALREADY.
ACTUALLY LET'S SEE NEXT YEAR'S
EDITION WE KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT
WILL BE HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
ADULTS IN THE CLASSROOM AND WE
NEED TO SEE THE ADDED ON
INVESTMENT IMPLEMENTING LAST
YEAR'S CLEAN. YES THAT THE
ADDITIONAL ON WHEN THREE
THIRTEEN PER STUDENT ADD UP TO A
- YES OVERSEE. SEVEN HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL. RIGHT NOW AND
BENEFITS PACKAGE EDUCATOR ADULTS
WOULD MOST LIKELY BE A PARA
EDUCATOR. RESEARCH RELEASED THE
POOR THAT ME THE BRICK TEACHER
RATIO S. S. FOR YOUNGER CHILDREN
RIGHT IMPACTS THE ACADEMIC AND
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL WELL BEING OF
STATE. FOR EXAMPLE WE KNOW FROM
RESEARCH THAT LOWER STAFF CHILD
RATIOS TEND TO BE LESS STRESSFUL
FOR TEACHERS WHICH CAN LEAD TO A
MORE EMOTIONAL SUPPORTIVE
ENVIRONMENT FOR CHILDREN. I YOU
THE LOWER STAFF TELEVISION AS
ALLOW FOR AFFECT USE GROUP IS.
WHICH CAN INCREASE CHILDREN'S
EXPOSURE TO LANGUAGE RICH
INTERACTIONS WITH ADULTS AND
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM
TO ENGAGE WITH ME. YES LAST WEEK
LOWER STAFF TURNOVER RATE HAVE.
AND PASTA RELATED TO MEASURES
PASS FROM ALEX LIKE ASK. ME RAIN
. AND THEN I OF THIS BILL. HAS
BE EVEN STRONGER IT INCLUDES
BACK KINDERGARTEN IN
KINDERGARTEN. I NEED WE'VE HEARD
FROM A THAT WHILE THE SUPPORT
EXPAND AT T. K. IN N. OF HEY
THEY COULD USE ADDITIONAL AND IF
YOU AREAS THAT POTENTIALLY
IMPACT THE FACE IN APPROACHING.
WORKING ON THE DIVERSE TEACHER
PIPELINE TO HAVE ADEQUATE
STAFFING YES PTK AND HAVE A
GREAT. REALLY NEED AROUND THAT
PLAYGROUNDS THE BACKGROUND THE
PARKING ENTRANCE BUT- OF LITTLE
. YOUR FOR YOUR OLD. AND. REST
THE NEED TO DO- K. EXPANSION. IN
ORDER TO HAVE A NASTY TO CREATE
A CLASSROOM WHILE OTHERS HAVE
THE NEED TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THAT THE INTO PAY AND NEED A FEW
AND YEARS THANK YOU FOR THE. AND
I HAVE STEVEN PARKER IN VIRGINIA
EARLY HERE WITH. TO ADDRESS ANY
OF. AT THE- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. OF THAT COMPLETE PANEL AND AS
I SAID. EARLIER WILL QUESTION
UNTIL PER AM ONE AND PANEL TO.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO PAN TO WHICH
IS TO LOCAL PER. IN THE FIRST OF
THE THREE SPEAK. WILL BE RE
ANDRADE THIS AND OF THE SALINAS
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL DISTRICT-
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. GOOD
MORNING ON A WHEELCHAIR LAYERED
AND MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE-
CENTERS MANAGER BONDS MY NAME IS
REBECCA AND WRITE A AND I'M THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE SALINAS
CITY ELEMENTARY SCHOOL DISTRICT.
I BEGAN SERVING IN THIS ROLE IN
JULY TWENTY TWENTY. OUR DISTRICT
IS LOCATED IN MONTEREY COUNTY
AND WE ARE ONE OF THE THIRD
LARGEST DISTRICTS IN MONTEREY
COUNTY WE SERVE STUDENTS IN
PRESCHOOL THROUGH GRADE SIX AT
FIFTEEN SCHOOLS. LET ME START BY
STATING HOW APPRECIATIVE I AM
FOR BOTH THE EXTENDED LEARNING
AND THE TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN AND PRESCHOOL
EXPANSION THAT OUR LEGISLATURE
AND GOVERNMENT IS PROVIDING. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INCREASE POSITIVE
STUDENT OUTCOMES IS MUCH MORE
ATTAINABLE WHEN THESE SERVICES
ARE AVAILABLE AS WELL AS THE
ABILITY TO MOVE OUR COMMUNITIES
OUT OF POVERTY. I AM GRATEFUL AS
A PROFESSIONAL AND ALSO AS A
PARENT. FROM A PERSONAL
PERSPECTIVE I WAS A STUDENT WHO
WOULD WALK FROM MY HIGH SCHOOL
TO PICK UP MY YOUNGER SIBLING
WHO HAD BEEN WAITING OUTSIDE OF
HIS ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AND
SUPERVISED. MANY TIMES WE THEN
WALKED TO OUR LOCAL LIBRARY AND
WAITED. FOR MANY HOURS UNTIL OUR
PARENTS WHO EACH WORK SEVERAL
JOBS WOULD PICK US UP AT SIX OR
SOMETIMES SEVEN PM OR WHEN THE
LIBRARY WAS CLOSING. IN MY EARLY
CAREER AS A TEACHER I ALSO HAD
SO MUCH OF MY SALARY GO TO
PROVIDE FOR PRESCHOOL AND CHILD
CARE. FOR MAKING TWO SONS AND I
KNOW THAT THIS IS THE REALITY
THAT MANY YOUNG EDUCATORS STILL
FACE TODAY. MY EXPERIENCE AND AT
THE EDUCATION FIELD INCLUDES NOT
JUST- PRINCIPLE BUT ALSO
DIRECTOR OF EXTENDED A
PRESCHOOL. AND I HAVE SERVED IN
PASADENA AND GLENDALE. I MENTION
THIS BECAUSE I KNOW FROM
EXPERIENCE HOW IT IS THAT A
SYSTEM CAN PROVIDE. SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS FROM SIX THIRTY AM TO
SIX PM. WE ARE NOT ALL AT THE
SAME LEVEL OF READINESS AND THIS
IS WHY I WANTED YOU TO HEAR THE
PERSPECTIVE THAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE. THERE IS A PERSISTENT
STAFFING SHORTAGE AND IN OUR
AREA IS CORRELATED TO A SCAR
CITY OF WORKFORCE HOUSING THAT
HINDERS RECRUITMENT EFFORTS. THE
NECESSARY FACILITY UPGRADES ARE
CONSIDERABLE AND REQUIRE
APPROVAL FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
SCHOOL ARCHITECTS AND THE
FORMATION OF BOARD ADVISORY
COMMITTEES ON SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION AS A CURRENT
FUNDING IS INSUFFICIENT. THE
PACE OF ADDING ANOTHER PUBLIC
GROUP HEALTH TO BROWN ACT
GUIDELINES CHALLENGES THE PACE
AT WHICH THE WORK- TO MEET THIS
MANDATE WILL MOVE IN OUR
DISTRICT. THE U. PICKET GUIDANCE
UP CAKE ITEMS WHICH- COVERS
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN NAMED-
YOU BECAME PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION GUIDANCE VOLUME
ONE. THAT YOU HEARD ABOUT IT IS
A VERY COMPREHENSIVE VERY
APPRECIATED IT WAS RECEIVED BY
DISTRICTS AND EVERY SEVENTEEN.
THE DEADLINE TO PROVIDE A BOARD
APPROVED PLAN IS JUNE THIRTIETH
. THE CITY REQUEST FOR
APPLICATIONS TO EXPAND STATE
PRESCHOOL- THE MANAGEMENT
BULLETIN FOR CSP PIECE WAS
PROVIDED YESTERDAY EVERY TWENTY
EIGHT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU IS
THERE ANY ABILITY TO PROVIDE
OUTRIGHT FUNDING NOT JUST
THROUGH GRANTS. IS THERE ANY
FURTHER OPPORTUNITIES TO PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY AS WITH THE REQUIRED
TWENTY FOUR E. C. UNITS. LOCAL
COLLEGES FROM COMMUNITY TO FOUR
YEAR INSTITUTIONS EXPAND THE
CURRENT CATALOG OF OFFERINGS
SOME OF US HERE THATTHERE ARE
BARRIERS WHEN THEY'RE TRYING TO
ENROLL IN OUR SYSTEM TO WORK ON
COURSE WORK FOR EDUCATION
BECAUSE THE CREDENTIALING
REQUIREMENTS ARE ONLY OFFERED IN
THE SPRING. OR SOMETIMES ONLY
OFFERED IN THE FALL DELAYING
THEIR CREDENTIALING. COULD THERE
BE INCENTIVES FOR ELLIE AS AND
OTHER LOCAL ENTITIES TO OFFER
TEACHER WORKFORCE HOUSING IN
THEIR AREA. AND I RETURNED TO
COULD PERHAPS SOME OF THE
SURPLUS IN OUR STATE BUDGET BE
ALLOCATED FOR THIS WILL
IMPLEMENTATION. THNK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE ALL
THIS WITH YOU AND KNOW THAT WE
ARE FULLY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS AND
ARE INTERESTED IN DEVELOPING A
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS POLICY. PLEASE NOTE THAT
THERE ARE MANY NEW
SUPERINTENDENTS IN OUR STATE
CURRENTLY AND MORE EXPECTED.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND-
THEN WE WILL ALL HOLD QUESTIONS
UNTIL THE END OF EVERYBODY ON
THE PNEL IN OUR NEXT SPEAKER IS
TANDY TAYLOR THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES FOR THE CYPRESS SCHOOL
DISTRICT- WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING SHARE
LAYERED MANY MEMBERS. NAME'S
DANNY TAYLOR FIRST I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
ALSO ONE OF RECOGNIZED THE CITY
AND THE COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION PROVIDE US- EXTRA
EXCELLENT RESOURCES. SCHOOL IS A
PASSIONATE SUBJECT OF MINE. I
WAS THE YOUNG CHILD YOU ARE
TRYINGTO SERVE THE CHILD OF A
HIGH SCHOOL PREGNANCY. OF A
CONSTRUCTION WORKER AND
WAITRESS. I WAS A YOUNG MOTHER
WHO WAS DESPERATE FOR A
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM WHEN I HAS
BEEN WAS TEMPORARILY DISABLE I
WAS WORKING FULL TIME AND GOING
TO SCHOOL FULL TIME. I WAS A
PRESCHOOL TEACHER WHO BECAME A
KINDERGARTEN TEACHER. I WAS
ASKED. AND NOW I'M AN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES OF THE CYBER SCHOOL
DISTRICT WHO OVERSEES THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM. I'M ALSO EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION EDUCATION
STATE COUNCIL PRESIDENT FOR
ACCESS OR THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
. IT IS THE ALL OF THESE LENSES
THAT TELLS ME UNIVERSAL
PRESCHOOL IS WHAT IS GOOD AND
RIGHT FOR THE CHILDREN OF OUR
GREAT STATE. THIS IS A HISTORIC
TIME WITH INVESTMENT AMBITION
FOR EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
AS LEADERS WE NEED TO ENSURE WE
DO IT RIGHT. AND THE ONLY WAY TO
DO THIS IS TO MAKE SURE WE
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES BEFORE US
. SOMETIMES THE CHALLENGES SEEM
DAUNTING. WHEN OTHER SOLUTIONS
AND I DON'T HAVE ALL THE
ANSWERS. WHAT I'VE DONE IS
LISTEN AND TALK TO MY FELLOW
COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE STATE. AND
I COME BEFORE YOU NOT ONLY WITH
TH CHALLENGES BUT ALSO WITH
SOME SUGGESTIONS FOR
CONSIDERATION. AS YOU HEARD THE
SAUDIS. IT DOESN'T MATTER IF
YOU'RE URBAN SUBURBAN RURAL
LARGE OR SMALL. WE NEED SPACE.
AND WE NEED BATHROOMS THAT ARE
MADE FOR LITTLE ONES AND WE NEED
PLACE SPACES. AND WIRE FACILITY
SO IMPORTANT TO SMALL YOUNG
CHILDREN. THE FULLY SUPPORT
YOUNG CHILDREN'S DEVELOPMENT
EMOTIONAL PHYSICAL AND
COGNITIVE. SKILLS CHILDREN NEED
ENOUGH SPACE TO ENSURE. IN PLAY
BASED LEARNING. ELDER
APPROPRIATE SIZE BATHROOMS
INAPPROPRIATE. THIS IS A SAFETY
ISSUE. FOUR YEAR OLD SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO WALK OUTSIDE TO USE THE
RESTROOM AND THEY REALLY
SHOULDN'T BE AFRAID OF FALLING
IN THE TOILET HERE. WE NEED
FUNDS EARMARKED FOR THESE
PURPOSES. WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY LOCATIONS GET THE
RENFREW GOALS AND COMPLETE THE
INSTALLATION. AND IF YOU'VE EVER
DONE CONSTRUCTION YOU KNOW THIS
IS NOT A QUICK PROCESS. THE
OTHER AREA STAFFING ISSUE PART.
AND THIS IS MULTI FACETED WE
CURRENTLY HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE
IN THE T. K. CLASSROOMS AND MAY
NEED TIME TO FINISH GETTING ALL
OF THEIR OPINIONS IT WOULD BE
IDEAL TO HAVE THE EXTENSION OF
THE CURRENT. AND CONSIDERATIONS
FOR THEM TO OBTAIN THEIR UNITS
WE ALSO NEED REALISTIC SOLUTIONS
FOR CREDENTIALING AND WE KNOW
THEY'RE BEING WORKED ON BUT THIS
NEEDS TO BE NOT ONLY PART
GENERAL EDUCATION BUT ALSO
SPECIAL EDUCATION. BUT ALSO ARE
PERMITTED EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION TEACHERS OR INTIMATELY
KNOWLEDGEABLE IN THE
FOUNDATIONAL SKILLS ASSESSMENTS
AND ROOM ENVIRONMENT FOR OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS. ADDITIONAL WE
ARE ALL STRUGGLING WITH STAFF
SHORTAGES AND WE NEED REAL
INCENTIVES TO BRING PEOPLE INTO
THE FIELD. IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO COMPETE WITH LOCAL BUSINESSES
WHO CAN OFFER FREE COLLEGE
SIGNING BONUSES AND PICK YOUR
OWN SCHEDULE AS WELL AS WORK
FROM HOME. FOR DISTRICTS THAT
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON
CORCORAN WE NEED ORDERED FOR
NATION. WE NEED LICENSING EXAM
BUILT INTO THE BILL WITHOUT IT
SCHOOLS WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
SEAMLESSLY INTEGRATE THEIR
PROGRAMS IN SCHOOL BASED
PROGRAMS AND WITH EXPANDED
LEARNING. WE NEED TO FULLY FUND
BY ENROLLMENT NOT ABA AS BEING
CONSIDERED FOR SCHOOLS. WE ALSO
NEED NEW ALLOCATIONS FOR
EXPANDING INTO TWO YEAR OLD BE
ABLE TO CONVERT FURNITURE AND
EQUIPMENT FOR HEALTH AND SAFETY
REASONS. TWO YEAR OLD CANNOT USE
FOUR YEAR OLD MATERIALS AND
EQUIPMENT. IF YOU'VE EVER DEALT
WITH THE TWO YEAR OLD IMAGINE
HAVING TWENTY FOUR OF THEM. NOW
LET US NOT FORGET OUR STUDENTS
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS ENGLISH
LEARNERS FOSTER YOU AND OTHER
CHILDREN. THAT HAVE EARLY THAT
NEED EARLY SUPPORTS WE NEED AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DEVELOP AND
TRAIN. ON WELL DESIGNED
INCLUSIVE INTEGRATED PROGRAMS.
OUR FOUR YEAR OLDS ARE UNIQUELY
THEIR OWN AGE GROUP WHAT THEIR
OWN DEVELOPMENT. OWN
DEVELOPMENTAL NEEDS THIS IS NOT
A MODIFIED KINDERGARTEN PROGRAM
. ROBUST MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT
WITH OUR EDUCATIONAL PARTNERS
NEED TIME. DO THE PANDEMIC JUST
SHORTLY GO EVERY DAY WHEN I WOKE
UP WE DID NOT KNOW WHICH JOB WE
WOULD BE DOING IN THE MORNING
MANY OF US TODAY ARE JUST COMING
UP FOR AIR AS YOU HEARD THE
GUIDANCE WAS JUST PRETTY PLEASE
WITH PLANTS THAT ARE DUE. IN
JUNE. WE NEED TIME TO DO THESE
PROPERLY AND MANY PEOPLE. BEFORE
MY DAD PASSED AWAY EVERY TIME HE
TALKED TO ME HE WAS HUMBLED THAT
A BLUE COLLAR WORKER AND REYES
MANAGEMENT. HE WOULD TELL ME HOW
PROUD HE WAS AND HE WOULD SHOW
ME MY BUSINESS CARD. AND HE
WOULD SAY. IT'S YOUR TURN TO
MAKE AN IMPACT. I APPROACH EVERY
DAY TO MAKE MY DAD PROUD. IT IS
WITH ALL MY HEART THAT I KNOW
TODAY IS THAT MOMENT. AS I LOOK
AT THE YOUNG CHILDREN RESEARCH
SIR I KNOW WE CAN MAKE. AND
SHAPE THE FUTURE. I BELIEVE OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS HAVE THE RIGHT
TO A DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
IN CHALLENGING EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAM THAT IS INTEGRATED WITH
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES WITH HIGH
EXPECTATIONS. IMPLEMENTED BY
WELL TRAINED COMPETENT AND
NURTURING STAFF. I JUST ASK YOU
TO GIVE US THE RESOURCES.
EQUIPMENT AND MOST OF ALL TIME.
TIME TO DO IT RIGHT. THANK. R.
I'M SORRY THE OF THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A QUESTION CAME. OUR
WEATHER THIS SITE PER SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS THE CYPRUS IT'S AN
ORANGE COUNTY IS THAT CORRECT
CORRECT OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- AND WILL HOLD ALL
QUESTIONS ON SUBSTANCE TO
LAUGHTER BOTH PANELS IN. THE
NEXT BOB PANELIST IN THE LAST ON
THIS WOMAN LOCAL PERSPECTIVES IS
JENNIFER HICKS THE ASSISTANT
SUPERINTENDENT OF EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES FOR THE PLASTER COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU HAVE A
BURNING TRAILER AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I'M JENNIFER HANDS
ASSISTANT SUPERINTENDENT OF
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES THAT THE
PLASTER COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. I'M ALSO THE CURRENT
CHAIR OF THE C. FASTER WHICH IS
CALIFORNIA COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES
ASSOCIATION. CURRICULUM AND
INSTRUCTION STEERING COMMITTEE
WE ARE AT COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
SERVING SIXTEEN DISTRICTS AND
TWELVE CHARTER SCHOOLS WE ALSO
HAPPEN TO OPERATE ALL OF THE
COUNTY STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS.
WE PROVIDE ACCESS TO SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE WE RUN THE LOCAL
PLANNING COUNCIL AND THE CHILD
RESOURCE NETWORK WRITTEN
REFERRAL NETWORK. FIRST I TO
TAKE A FEW MOMENTS THIS MORNING
TO SHARE HOW WE ARE WORKING TO
SUPPORT OUR ELEAZAR IN
TRANSITIONING TO SERBIA ALL THE
CASE. AND FOUR YEAR OLDS. I'M
RECENTLY IN JANUARY THROUGH SAYS
CAN SEE FAST THAT WE PUBLISHED A
UNIVERSAL PLANNING TOOL KIT
WHICH IS A RESOURCE GUIDE FOR
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION. AND
IS MEANT TO BE A COMPANION
DOCUMENT TO THE UNIVERSAL PRE
KINDERGARTEN PLANNING TEMPLATE
WHICH MISSED LEVEL MORGAN JUST
PREFERRED TO. THE COUNTY OFFICE
TOOL KIT PROVIDES RESOURCES AND
APPROACHES AND EXAMPLES IN
INFORMATION FOR COUNTY OFFICES
TO SUPPORT DIFFERENT DISTRICTS.
AROUND AREAS OF HE THREE VISION
AND COHERENCE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT AND PARTNERSHIPS
WORKFORCE RECRUITMENT AND
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING.
CURRICULUM INSTRUCTION AND
ASSESSMENT AND FACILITIES.
SERVICES AND OPERATIONS. YOU'RE
A CLASSIC OFFICE OFFICE BUDGET.
WE'VE BEEN MEETING WITH ALL OF
OUR ELEAZAR BEGINNING LAST
OCTOBER WE MEET MONTHLY AS A U.
P. K. NETWORK AND WE USE THIS
TIME TO COLLABORATE TO SHARE
RESOURCES AND INFORMATION. TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
SHARE IDEAS AND PROBLEM SOLVED.
FROM THIS GROUP WE HAVE
DEVELOPED A WORK GROUP THAT'S
CALLED THE CURRICULUM AND
INSTRUCTION UTK WORKGROUP. THIS
IS A GROUP THAT'S WORKING ON
CURRICULUM DEVELOPMENT AND
ENSURING THAT THE TEACHING
CURRICULUM THAT ARE LEDS WILL BE
USING. A BALANCE OF
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
ACTIVITIES SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING AND ACADEMICS. IN
ADDITION DURING THESE MONTHLY
PEAK WORK MEETING AND ARE COUNTY
DONE BY CHIU BASE PARTNER. SUCH
AS HEADS THE LOCAL TO CHAO THE
RESTORE EMERGED MATT. AND OTHER
AFTER SCHOOL AND CARE PROVIDERS
IN OUR COMMUNITY TO HAVE THESE
DISCUSSIONS WITH US AND HELP
PROBLEM SOLVED AND THINK THROUGH
HOW WE CAN BEST PROVIDE AN
ALLIANCE AND COMPARING U. P. K.
SYSTEM. ADDITION COUNTY OFFICE
ARE PLAYING A STRONG IN
SUPPORTING AND BUILDING THE
CAPACITY FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. FOR EXAMPLE TCO WE
SUBMITTED ONE OF THOSE LETTERS
OF INTENT AND FITNESS NOBLE NOR
GET MORTGAGE AND REFERENCED
EARLIER FOR THE EARLY EDUCATION
TEACHER DEVELOPMENT GRANT. WE
SUBMITTED ON BEHALF OF OUR
COUNTY AS WELL AS SIX OTHER
SMALLER COUNTY OFFICES IN OUR
IMMEDIATE REGION. OUR INTENT AS
THE COUNTY OFFICES TO PROVIDE
MULTIPLE PATHWAYS FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FOR THOSE INTERESTED
IN CAREERS IN P. THREE
EDUCATION. AND I'LL SHARE SOME
EXAMPLES OF WHAT THAT WOULD LOOK
LIKE FIRST WE HAVE ALREADY
ENTERED INTO AN AGREEMENT IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SIERRA
COLLEGE. AND WE ARE PROVIDING
ACCESS AND STARTING A COHORT
THIS MARCH THAT WILL PROVIDE
TWENTY FOUR ECT UNITS OF COURSE
WORK FOR ALL OF OUR CURRENT
MULTIPLE SUBJECT TEACHERS THAT
NEED TO ADD THOSE TWENTY FOUR
UNITS. IN ORDER TO BE ELIGIBLE
TO TEACH THREE K. OUR FIRST
COHORT AS I MENTIONED BEGINS IN
MARCH AND THEY WILL COMPLETE
THOSE TWENTY FOUR UNITS WITHIN
TWO YEARS WHICH COINCIDES WITH
THE DEADLINE. FOR FULL
IMPLEMENTATION. I IN ADDITION
OUR PARTNERS WITH YOUR CALL A WE
AND- TO DEVELOP A THREE AND
CRITIC PRO. ONCE A PRE BY THE ON
TEACHER. AS A COUNTY WEEK
PROVIDE. OTHER SPECIES APPROVED
CREDENTIAL PROGRAMS SO OUR
INTENT IS TO ADD THIS TO OUR
PORTFOLIO IN SUPPORT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IN THIS AREA. WE
WILL ALSO BE PROVIDING ACCESS TO
THOSE TWENTY FOUR UNITS OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION CREDITS
THROUGH SIERRA COLLEGE FOR ALL
OF OUR EARLY EDUCATORS WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN ADVANCING THEIR
CAREERS AND EARLY EDUCATION. FOR
EXAMPLE SOMEONE WHO IS AN
ASSOCIATE TEACHER AND I STATE
PRESCHOOL CAN TAKE ADDITIONAL
UNITS- WITH SIERRA COLLEGE
BEYOND PROMOTES U. S. SITE
SUPERVISOR OR A MASTER TEACHER.
AND THEN FINALLY THROUGH THIS
GRANT OUR HOPE IS TO PROVIDE
GENERAL PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
FOR BOTH TEACHERS AND PARA
EDUCATOR PARA EDUCATORS. ON
EARLY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT SO
THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO BETTER
SUPPORT T. PAY LIMITATION IN THE
CLASSROOM. AS PART OF AB ONE
THIRTY THE CALIFORNIA PRE
KINDERGARTEN PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION GRANT PROGRAM
WHICH PROVIDES FUNDING
EXPLICITLY FOR COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION TO SUPPORT COUNTY
WHY'D YOU BE K. PLANNING
CAPACITY BUILDING. WHILE THESE
FUNDS ARE ONE TIME OUR HOPE IS
THAT ONGOING FUNDING WILL ALLOW
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION TO
PROVIDE THIS CRITICAL SUPPORT
COORDINATION AND TECHNICAL
SYSTEMS ON A LONG TERM BASIS.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO SHARE SOME
EXAMPLES ABOUT HOW OUR STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS ARE ADAPTING
TO THE CHANGING NEEDS OF U. T.
PAY. FIRST WE IN OUR COMMUNITY
ARE ADVOCATING AND SUPPORTING
AND NEXT DELIVERY SYSTEM WHICH
INCLUDES TRANSITIONAL KERR
KINDERGARTEN STATE PRESCHOOL
HEAD START COMMUNITY BASED ON
FAMILY CHILD CARE SYSTEMS AND WE
REALLY SEE THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND SERVICE TO
MORE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IN
OUR COMMUNITY. OUR INTENT IS TO
EXPAND OUR STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM INTO SPECIFIC AREAS
FIRST TO PROVIDE SERVICE TO TWO
YEAR OLDS FOR SPACE ALLOWANCE
AND ONCE WE GET CHANGING TABLES
PURCHASED FOR DIAPERING. I'M IN
SECOND IS WE HAVE BEEN MEETING
WITH ALL OF OUR DISTRICTS WHO
HOSTS THE STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM ON THEIR SITE AND
DISCUSSING EXPANSION THROUGH
INTO A BLENDED DELIVERY MODEL
THAT WOULD SUPPORT THE AUSTRIAN
OF NINE HOURS OF PROGRAMMING. SO
FOR EXAMPLE A CHILD COULD GO TO
A DISTRICT HE CAME PROGRAM IN
THE MORNING AND THEN WALK ACROSS
CAMPUS AND GO TO A STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM IN THE
AFTERNOON. THEN THEY WOULD ONLY
BE REQUIRED TO HAVE A COUPLE OF
ADDITIONAL HOURS OF EXTENDED
CARE THAT ALLOWS THE DISTRICT
YOU HAVE ONE TEACHER TEACHING
AND KIÞM CLASS AND THEN WE
PROVIDE AN A. M. AND PM STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM. WE'RE ALSO
ABLE TO ENSURE THAT THE CHILD'S
DEVELOPMENTAL NEEDS ARE BEING
MET THROUGH. TRADITIONAL
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM. I'M ACTUALLY
ME WITH THE IN. FOLLOWING
SESSION M. AS WE EXPANDING TO
PLANT TO EXPAND AT THREE OF
THEIR SCHOOL SITES. ONE OF OUR
GOALS THROUGH THIS WORK AS
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION IS
TO REALLY EMPHASIZE AND DEVELOP
THIS IDEA OF THE P. THREE
CONTINUE ONE. AND TO BE LOOKING
AT EDUCATION FROM THIS
PERSPECTIVE WE PLASTER COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
HIRING A P. THREE COORDINATOR TO
SUPPORT THIS WORK WITH THE BIG
EMPHASIS ON ALIGNING CURRICULUM
ACROSS P. THREE. WE ARE ALSO
LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR DISTRICT
STAFF TO VISIT- HIGH QUALITY
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS. ONE OF
OUR LESSONS LEARNED THROUGH THIS
PROCESS SINCE LAST OCTOBER IS
THAT WE HAVE WORK TO DEAL AND
EDUCATING OUR ELEAZAR. AROUND
WHAT THE NEXT DELIVERY MODEL
COULD LOOK LIKE MANY WERE SIMPLY
NOT AWARE OF THE OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FOUR YEAR OLD
CHILDREN SUCH AS STATE PRESCHOOL
SUBSIDIZED PROGRAMS AND SOME OF
THE OTHERS THAT I MENTIONED
EARLIER. ARE ALSO ENGAGING IN
DISCUSSION AND BRAINSTORMING
AROUND MARKETING AND
COMMUNICATION HOW DO WE BEST
INFORM OUR FAMILIES. OF THE
DIFFERENT CHOICES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE TO THEM FOR
THEIR FOUR YEAR OLD. FINALLY I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
AND SHARE DEEP APPRECIATION FOR
THE PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION. IN CVS AS
WE HAVE BEEN ENGAGED IN A BOTTLE
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION. HI
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS. AND WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO QUESTIONS NOW AND IN
A MOMENT I'M GOING TO ASK EVERY
MEMBER OF PANEL ONE. TO COMMENT
ON WHAT WAS STATED IN PANEL TWO
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE A FEEDBACK
ON SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT
WERE RAISED BY THE- LOCAL
PERSPECTIVE BUT MAYBE. IN A
MOMENT BEFORE WE DO THAT I CAN
FRAME THAT BECAUSE I THINK THAT.
THAT IN MANY WAYS. WE JUST DID
THIS IN THE LAST BUDGET THE
EXPANSION. IT IS GEARING UP WE
DO NOT HAVE DATA BECAUSE
EXPANSION HASN'T REALLY HAPPENED
WE'RE JUST HAVING APPLICATIONS
GO OUT AND YET. THE PANELISTS ON
THE LOCAL PERSPECTIVES JUST
RAISED A LIST OF CONCERNS AND
THEIR CONCERNS THAT IF WE CAN
ADDRESS THEM NOW WILL NOT BE
MORE CUTE NEXT YEAR WHEN WE'RE
HAVING THE SAME OVERSIGHT AFTER
THE IMPLEMENTATION ACTUALLY
STARTS AND WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THOSE ISSUES NOW. AS THE
IMPLEMENTATION RAMPS UP SO WHAT
WE GO THROUGH ALL THREE MEMBERS
OF A PANEL ONE STARTING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THEN
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST AND
THEN. OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND ASK IF YOU WOULD
COMMENT ON WHAT WE HEARD FROM
LOCAL PERSPECTIVES AND ALL BEGIN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WE KNOW GRANT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- WAS DEFINITELY HELPFUL
TO HEAR THE LOCAL PERSPECTIVES
AND WE'RE CERTAINLY AWARE OF THE
STAFFING SHORTAGE IT'S AN ISSUE
THAT. KIND OF SPANS ACROSS OUR
VARIOUS INVESTMENTS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET A WE'RE AWARE
OF THIS ISSUE AND- WE'RE JUST
WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO BE
SENSITIVE AND IN THE WAY WE- YOU
KNOW IMPLEMENT SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS PROVIDING SOME
FLEXIBILITIES AND- KIND OF
IMPLEMENTATION- FLEXIBILITY.
KNOWING THAT THESE ISSUES ARE
ARE PERSISTENT AND- SAME GOES
FOR FACILITIES- ISSUES IS NOT MY
AREA OF EXPERTISE BUT I- I'M
AWARE THAT MY COLLEAGUES AT THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE ARE ALSO THAT
HAVE BEEN HEARING THE SAME
ISSUES. IN THEIR DIFFERENT AREAS
SO WE'RE ACTIVELY- TAKING THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION AS WE- YOU
KNOW WORK ON DEVELOPING AND
IMPROVING OUR- OUR GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL OR THE MAY
REVISION- AND THERE'S ANYTHING
ELSE YOU'D SPECIFICALLY WANTED
ME TO COMMENT ON HAPPY TO OR MY
COLLEAGUE CHRIS FERGUSON. ALSO
ON THE LINE IN AN AD THANK YOU I
THINK WE MIGHT GET TO SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS AFTER WE GET TO THE
MORE GENERAL RESPONSE. SO LET ME. GO TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. I THINK WE
HAVE TO ON MUTE EDGAR CABRAL. HE
IS STILL MUTED. YOU CAN ON MUTE
MR CABRAL I THINK NOW. OF THE. I
THINK HE MAY BE FROZEN SO ARE
ORG SKEWS ME HIS IMAGE ON THE
SCREEN IS FROZEN HE MAY BE VERY
MALLEABLE OF SO WHILE HE
ATTEMPTS TO RECONNECT WHAT'S GO
TO SERRA NOVEL A MORGAN- OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THERE AND OF A
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ANYTHING THAT SECOND
PACKED WITH THE PANELISTS ECHOED
AGAIN REALLY REINFORCED SOME OF
THE ITEMS THAT WE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAVE
BEEN HEARING AND PRODUCT EARLIER
IN MY TESTIMONY. SO THEY DIVERSE
TEACHER PIPELINE ENSURING THAT
THERE'S ADEQUATE SUPPORT AND WE
HAVE THAT A HUNDRED MILLION BUT
WE THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
QUICKLY TAKEN UP. KNOWING THAT
WE HAVE ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
LETTERS OF INTENT I REQUEST
AROUND THOSE FUNDS RIGHT NOW.
AND KNOWING THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THEM AND IT IS WITH IN
HIGHER ED AS PART OF THAT WELL
TO REALLY ADDRESS BOTH THE
TWENTY FOUR UNIT. MAKING SURE
THAT THEY ARE APPLICABLE TO
WORKING WITH YOUNGER CHILDREN
AND OTHER ACCESSIBLE FOR PEOPLE
WHO ALREADY HAVE A TEACHING
CREDENTIAL HE GOT TRAIL WE ALSO
WANT TO LIFT UP OUR STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM IN THEIR
TEACHERS AND PART OF THAT SAID
THAT. THOSE SUPPORTS ACROSS THAT
PLATE THING ARE THERE ANYTHING
THIS TAKES REALLY SPENT TWO MUCH
TIME. AT LEAST. HEARING FROM ALL
OF THEM NEED FOR. NOT JUST THE
ROOM IF THEY- FELT BUT HE THE
BATHROOM THE TOILET. THE STATE.
THAT WATER FOUND. WHERE THE
PLAYGROUNDS. THE HARDWARE. CAN
TO DROP. AT THE ACT USUALLY TO.
AND WALK THERE FOR YOUR OWN IN
THE REALLY. SURE SOME OF THE
ISSUES AROUND PARKING ENTRANCE
THE- THOUGH WHERE THERE NEED TO
BE PROCESS FACED SAYS HAVE YOU.
MOVE ENTRANCE. OF YEAR OLD. ALL
BEEN PART OF WHY. SEPTEMBER AND
- EXPRESSED THEIR READY TO NOW
AND THEY WOULD LIE TO BE A TO
DRAW DOWN. THIS EIGHT NINE.
IMMEDIATELY FOR ALL FOUR YEAR
OLDS. IN ORDER TO FILL UP A- IN
PAPERBACK. AND OTHERS ARE REALLY
EXPRESSING THAT THEY MIGHT NEED
A COUPLE ADDITIONAL YEARS. TO BE
ABLE TO FULLY IMPLEMENTED. THANK
YOU K. AND U. PK BECAUSE OF
THOSE ISSUES AROUND TEACHERS.
AND FACILITY- I'M- TRYING TO
THINK IF THERE WAS MORE THERE.
LIKE THAT THE COMMISSION I
TEACHER CREDENTIALING IS WORKING
ON THAT YEAH THREE. AND FOUR THE
- SPECIALIST CREDENTIAL INSTEAD
THEY HAVE A GROUP THAT'S REALLY
DIVING IN VERY QUICKLY. AND
KUDOS. DANNY TINA ATP FOR THAT
WE ARE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH ALL
OF OUR SUPPORT AROUND YOU CAME
WITH THEM. AND STILL NEED VERY
REGULARLY ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE
WORK. HAPPY PAID PLAYING NEED.
ANY OTHER PURPOSE. BRING UP FROM
SOME OF THE OF THE COMPANIES.
ISSUES AROUND OUR STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM MAKING SURE
THAT THAT. IS THAT THE TEACHERS
AND THAT COMPENSATION. AS YOU
LOOK AT TWO YEAR OLD ENTERING
PRE K. ALL THE WAY UP THROUGH
THOSE FOUR AND FIVE YEAR OLD
ENOUGH. AND THAT WE REALLY HAVE.
THE ABILITY TO ACCESS HIGH.
QUALITY EFFECTIVE TEACHING THAT
. AND THEN I LASTLY I THINK I
HEARD SOMETHING. BILL THE LEADER
. AGENDA MORE AROUND THE- ON.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT TV IS A
ABOUT. BUT DOES IT WILL LOOK FOR
HIGH LIKE THE NEW TO ADDRESS THE
T. AS WELL AS- DESIGN LEARNING
LEARNING SO THAT EMPIRE AND NOT
EIGHT WHEN WE REALLY AREN'T
SURE. THAT AND- IS OF ANY
UNIVERSAL KINDERGARTEN MOVE TO
ENACT THAT CAN IS MAKING ANY
OTHER PART WITH THAT IS THE FOR
YOUR DEALING WITH. AND HER A
LITTLE BIT OF THAT BUT WILL
BRING IT UP EVEN MORE NO THAT
60% OF HER CHILDREN UNDER I
THINK HELLO. FAMILIES THAT A
LANGUAGE OTHER THAN. THAT WE
HIGHLIGHT THE NEED TO WITH. AND
STUFF DUOLINGO LEARNING AND MAKE
SURE THAT TEACH WORK FOR I. IS
ABLE TO MORE. TO GET SUPPORT
WILL IMMERSION PROGRAM. THEN
HAVE BEEN REJOINED EARTH YOU FOR
THE COMMENTS WE BEEN REJOINED
BY. A CABRAL OF THE- ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND WILL RECOGNIZE YOU
FOR ANY COMMENTS IN RESPONSE.
YES THANK YOU AND I APOLOGIZE
FOR THE TECHNICAL ISSUES- I'M-
JUST NOT- I THINK MANY OF THE
CONCERNS THAT- THE BELL BOTTOM
ON PANEL TO MENTIONED- MARK OUR
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE. HEARD
BEFORE- WE RECOGNIZE THAT. THERE
IS A PARTICULAR CHALLENGE OF.
WITH FACILITIES AND STAFFING AND
IT'S AN IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO MONITOR. AS IT
IMPLEMENTS- THESE PROGRAMS THAT
. EXTENSION OF UNIVERSAL I'M
PROVISIONAL CAN ARE NAY WOOD IT
IS FIVE WILL BE A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN
THAT ARE BEING STARTED SO I'M
RECOGNIZE. THAT THERE WOULD BE
SOME- NEED TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
. BUT OR SUPPORTED WAYS HELP
ADDRESS ISSUES. I THINK WHAT
WHEN IT COMES TO- IT ALL WATER
RECORD THINK OBVIOUSLY THE LEAD
AWAY MONITOR AND SEE WHAT WHAT
ISSUE. ARISE. IT IS ALSO A THE
WAY THEY WE APPROACH THIS BUDGET
I WOULD SAY IS THAT WE YOU KNOW
THERE ARE SO- SIGNIFICANT-
THINGS THAT WERE A AGREED UPON
LAST YEAR BUT IN THE BUDGET.
UNIVERSAL TRADITION KINDERGARTEN
BEING ONE OF THEM- IN ADDITION
EXAMPLE UNIVERSAL MEALS ON THE
TELEVISION SIDE I THINK WE TAKE
THAT THE PERSON WE'VE TAKEN TO
REVIEWING THE PROPOSALS THIS
YEAR IS THAT THOSE ARE THE
PRIORITY BECAUSE THOSE HAVE BEEN
AGREED UPON AND IF THE- IF THERE
ARE CAPACITY ISSUES WOULD BE
AVAILABLE BUT PERHAPS WE SHOULD
SAY DO FEWER THINGS IN THIS
BUDGET. YOUR NEW DIGS SO FOR
EXAMPLE ON THE GLOVES THAT YOU
CAN DO IS SAY NOT ADOPT AS MANY
NEW COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAMS
OR IMPLEMENT NEW INITIATIVES AND
FOCUS ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THOSE THAT ARE THAT ARE- PART OF
WHAT LAST YEAR. I THINK THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF THESE ISSUES
THAT CAN BE VERY COMPLICATED AS
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THAT THAT THAT
THAT CAN BE A CHALLENGE THE
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN WAS
FEES BEEN IN PART TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES BUT- WE
KNOW THAT THE STAFFING- ISSUES
HAVE BEEN PROPERLY SUBSTANTIAL.
ONE THING I WOULD NOTE- JUST A
SMALL PIECE BUT IN TERMS OF THE
TWENTY FOUR UNITS ARE OF YOU SEE
THAT HAVE BEEN MENTIONED THIS
WAS A REQUIREMENT- WAS SUPPOSED
TO TAKE EFFECT IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IN AUGUST OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE FOUR- TRADITIONAL GUITAR
TEACHERS TO HAVE TWENTY FOUR
UNITS EVERY CD. THAT IN THE LAST
BUDGET WAS DELAYED TO AUGUST OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE SO THERE IS
A LITTLE BIT OF BUFFER BUT ONE
UNDER CURRENT LAW ONCE YOU GET
THE TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR THE
EXPECTATION OF THAT- TAKING
PICTURES HAVE THOSE UNITS AND
SO. I THINK THAT'S THAT'S PART
OF THE CONCERN THAT THAT READING
IT'S NOT AN ISSUE RIGHT NOW WITH
GETTING TEACHERS IN THE
CLASSROOM NOW BUT IT WILL BE.
AND IN. THE TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR FISCAL YEAR. I THANK YOU
ARE ARMED OF. UP WITH QUESTION
FISH. TO THOSE THREE PER. BUT
BEFORE I THAT. LET ME. BUT OFF
OF A CALM. THAT MR COOPER MADE.
IN RISK. TO OR RELY. TO A
COMMENT MADE BY TEN DETAILER. OF
THE CYBER SCHOOL DISTRICT
BECAUSE- SHE MENTIONED THAT SHE
THOUGHT IT WAS VERY IMPORTANT TO
MOVE TO ANOTHER. MOMENT SYSTEMS.
UP FROM THE AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE. AND WHILE MANY OF
THE SUPPORT THAT. WE HAVE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE THAT
WOULD WIN AND WAS UNDER THAT.
DRAMATICALLY IN MANY CASES THE
LOS ANGELES SCHOOL DISTRICT
WOULD GAIN OF BILLION DOLLARS
UNDER UNDER ENVIRONMENT SYSTEM
BUT IF IT REMAINS IN PROP NINETY
EIGHT AND IT'S A FIX HI. OTHER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE TO LOSE A
BILLION DOLLARS TO BE ABLE TO
FUND THE MOMENT SYSTEM SO THE
WAY THAT IT WILL WORK IS IF WE
MADE AN ALLOCATION OF THREE
BILLION DOLLARS. SO THAT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT LOSE ARE
HELD HARMLESS BY THOSE THAT
GAINED GAINED AND THE AGGREGATE
OF THREE BILLION DOLLARS WHAT
THAT MEANS IS THAT WHEN WE
WALKED AT TO WHAT MR CABRAL JUST
REFERRED TO. AS TRYING TO NARROW
NEW THINGS IN THE ON GOING
FUNDING THAT THREE BILLION THEN
COMPETES AGAINST MANY OF THE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE TO DO HERE
OR THE THREE BILLION FOR HOME TO
SCHOOL FOUND- TRANSPORTATION OR
THE TWO POINT THREE BILLION THAT
WERE SHORT. IN THE INCREASE IN
PERSON STORES TO THE DISTRICTS
WE COULD BUY THAT DOWN WITH ONE
TIME MONEY BUT THEN THAT'S AN
ONGOING THING FOR THE NEXT
YEAR'S BUDGET IN TWO POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS THAT UNLESS WE-
AND WHAT WE HEARD FROM EVERYONE.
IN OUR HEARING ON PROP NINETY
EIGHT IS THAT THE COST OF LIVING
INCREASE IN PROP NINETY EIGHT
DOES NOT COVER EXPENSES THAT
THAT WE REALLY NEW TO NEED A
BIGGER BASE TO K. THROUGH TWELVE
DISTRICTS. WITH THE ONGOING PROP
NINETY EIGHT MONEY SO AS I MOVED
TO THE FACILITIES QUESTION YOU
<c.green>AN SEE THAT FOR US DECIDING</c>
WHAT TO PRIORITIZE ALL THOSE
THINGS COMPETE AGAINST EACH
OTHER. AND WE ARE TRYING TO MEET
THE NEEDS BUT- IT JUST-
ADVOCATING FOR MOVE TO THE
ENROLLMENT SYSTEM ABSENT
DESCRIBING HOW MUCH MONEY IT
WOULD COST TO COMPETE AGAINST
EVERYTHING ELSE IS JUST
SOMETHING I WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT.
NOT TO DRILL DOWN ON LITTLE
WITH. FINANCE CHAU AND- THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ON THE
CELL WHAT HE'S- THE THING I WANT
TO DROP IS THE TIME FOR. BECAUSE
WE REALLY ASKING TO EXPAND
STARTING IN THE NEXT YEAR THE
BUDGET YEAR. AND THEY WILL NEED
THE FACILITIES THAT AND
EVERYBODY I THINK ALL SIX
PANELISTS SAID FACILITIES WERE
AN ISSUE AND WE NEED TO DO IT.
HOW DO WE ADDRESS THE NEED FOR
FACILITIES WHICH WILL START IN
THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT AS PART OF THIS
EXPANSION WE HAVE ACTUALLY
ADDRESS THAT. TO SYNCHRONIZE
WITH EVERYBODY EXPANDING AT IT
DURING THE TIME OF THE
FACILITIES NAY DID NOT START
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINE.
GERMAN NOT CHRIS FOR YOU SOME OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL ALL
FIELD THAT I THINK. WE PUT
FORWARD SEVERAL- WE'VE WE PUT
FORWARD A COUPLE CONCEPTS THAT
WE THINK CAN BE HELPFUL IN THIS
AREA THE FIRST AS WE DEFINITELY
ENCOURAGE OUR- LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES TO BE WORKING WITH. OUR
PRESCHOOL PROVIDERS AND OTHER
AYE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO BLEND AND BREAK
PROGRAMS THAT CAN ULTIMATELY.
YOU KNOW PROVIDE FOR A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH. TO
SERVING THE STUDENTS. OF WE'VE
ALSO PUT FORWARD OVER TO YOUR- A
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE TWO POINT
ONE BILLION DOLLARS. TO SUPPORT
THE SCHOOL FACILITIES PROGRAM-
WITHIN THAT PROGRAM THE WAY
ELIGIBILITY BUT YOU CONSTRUCTION
WORKS IT IS HIGHLY LIKELY THAT
MANY DISTRICTS WOULD HAVE-
ELIGIBILITY FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION
FUNDS TO CONSTRUCT CLASSROOMS-
FOR I. T. K. SO CERTAINLY YOU
KNOW THERE ARE SOME CORRELATED-
PROPOSALS IN THAT AREA. I AND
YOU KNOW ULTIMATELY OTHER ALSO
LOCAL BONDING RESOURCES IN MANY
DISTRICTS THAT CAN BE AVAILABLE
TO SUPPORT THE FACILITIES NEEDS.
AS WELL AS THE RECENT DATA FROM.
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
WHICH INDICATED THAT. THERE WERE
SOME- EIGHTY EIGHT DECLINES IN.
THE VERY SPECIFIC WE ARE K.
THREE THREE YEAH GREAT SPANNER
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH GRADE
CERTAINLY THERE MAY BE SOME
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY YOU KNOW TO
SERVE STUDENTS. IN OUR
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN.
PROGRAMS I IN THE TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR HOUR CHART TWENTY
TWENTY THREE FISCAL YEAR- AS
THEY BEGIN TO RAMP UP CERTAINLY
WE MONITOR WE'RE MONITORING THAT
SITUATION. BUT WE DEFINITELY
ENCOURAGE TO HELP YOU KNOW WITH
FACILITIES- ARE WORKING TO BLEND
IN PRETTY DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
TOGETHER AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
BEFORE I MOVED TO THE ONLY- LET
ME. DO A COUPLE OF FOLLOW UPS
FIRST. YOU MENTIONED FACILITIES
MONEY BUT IS THERE IS THAT
UNIQUELY FOR THIS PROGRAM OR IS
THAT WITHIN THE FACILITIES MONEY
THAT IS. SORT OF BRIDGING US THE
NEXT YEAR TO FOR ALL. K. THROUGH
TWELVE FACILITIES. THAT WOULD BE
BRIDGE OUT FOR TAKE FACILITIES
SO LOOKING RAIN THAT INCLUDE BY
PRE K. WITH THEN COME. FOR
DISTRICT THAT DON'T HAVE
CAPACITY OR HAVE OUTDATED
FACILITIES THAT ARE TRYING TO
APPLY FOR MONEY AND THAT THIS
WOULD THEN COMPETE WITH THAT IS
THAT. OF THE CASE. YES CERTAINLY
THAT WOULD BE THE CASE OKAY AND
THEN AND THEN ONE COMMENT BEFORE
WE MOVE ON- WANTED TO TALK ABOUT
LOCAL BONDING CAPACITY. IN MY
VIEW THAT THEN BECOMES AN EQUITY
ISSUE BECAUSE I THINK THAT THE
LOWER INCOME OR DISADVANTAGED
DISTRICTS HAVE LESS OF A
CAPACITY TO PASS BONDS. AND SO
THEN IF WERE LONG ON BONDS TO DO
THIS. IT IT REALLY FAVORS
DISTRICTS THAT ARE. OUR
ADVANTAGE TO THOSE THAT ARE
DISADVANTAGED JUST FOR THE
RECORD OF WHAT'S MOVED TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST ON DRILLING
DOWN ON FACILITIES ANY COMMENTS
THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE. YEAH I
THINK WE FOR THE NUMBER OF
CONCERNS AS WELL ON THIS ISSUE
AND I THINK WE DO RECOGNIZE
THAT. WITH OF THESE ISSUES THEY
DO TAKE TIME- WE HAVE HEARD.
ABOUT THE SEARCH OF THE PROCESS
IT TAKES TO GET A BIG. THROUGH
THE STATE THROUGH THE- YOU KNOW
THE STATE BECAUSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FOR THE BILL BACK IT'S
A LITTLE BIT MORE OF A OF A- I'M
INTENSIVELY THE PROCESS. I'M I
WOULD NOT THAT THE STATE DID IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET THERE WAS FOR
AND NINE MILLION DOLLARS THAT
WAS PROVIDED. I WAS INTENDED TO
BE FOR FACILITIES RELATED EARLY
EDUCATION I THOUGHT THIS WAS
FUNDING A COULD BE USED FOR. A
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN FOR
STATE PRESCHOOL OFFER FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN SO THE STATE HAS
PROVIDED SOME FUNDING- A
QUESTION WOULD BE WHETHER THERE
NEEDS TO BE ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
PROVIDED TO MEET THE DEMAND I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WORKED OUT. THAT WE ARE
MONITORING I THINK THAT THE OPC
OF THE WOMEN'S- MONITORING THAT
PROGRAM AND ITS IMPLEMENTATION.
IT DEFINITELY COULD BE A BETTER
THERE MIGHT BE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING NEEDED I WOULD NOTE
THAT- THAT FUNDING IS NON PROFIT
NINETY EIGHT WITH A FUNDING IN
GENERAL FUND- SO IT'S- JUST LIKE
THE SCHOOL FACILITY GRANT
PROGRAM- IS NOT NINETY EIGHT SO
IT. DOESN'T COMPETE WITH OTHER
EDUCATION. PROGRAMS BUT IT DOES-
IT DOES MEAN THAT IT'S COMING
OUT OF OTHER THAN THE NOMINEE
GENERAL FUND. FIVE IT CAN BE
BECAUSE OF FACILITIES AND THEN
THAT WOULD BE FOR EXCLUDED FROM
THE STATE APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT
IF YOU WERE TO PURSUE THAT
OPTION BUT- ARMY IT IS ANOTHER-
IT'S ONE WAY TO TRY TO PROVIDED
SUPPORT IT IS SOMETHING THAT THE
STATE HAS ALREADY. STARTED DO.
THANK YOU. JACOB AND ANASTA
DEPARTMENT OF A TO RECEIVE-
FACILITIES. THANK YOU VERY
WORKING WITH DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THE BUILDING OFF THE
MR KRAUSS AND MR FORGET ADD WE
CANNOT IGNORE AND APPRECIATE THE
OFFICE PUBLIC CONSTRUCTION IS
LEADING UP THE SPOT. THOUGH
DOING IT IN OVER TO THE SINCE
THAT THOSE DISTRICTS ARE READY
TO GO. WITH THEIR PLAN TO APPLY
THIS YEAR OR A TO FEEL IT AND
THEN GIVING A BIT MORE TIME FOR
THOSE NEED ADDITIONAL CARE. WE
WOULD ECHO MR PROBABLY YOU THINK
IT IS SOMETIMES WOULD BE NEED
THE FOUR HUNDRED AND MILLION
MIGHT NOT A LOT OF FAITH AND HOW
. WITH THE AMOUNT OF NEED ACROSS
STATE AS WE ADDRESS OUR
PRESCHOOL T. K. AND KINDERGARTEN
FACILITY I THINK AND MAKING SURE
THAT THOSE CLASSROOMS AND SPACE
ARE REALLY APPROPRIATE FOR OUR
EARLIEST YOUNGEST LEARNERS. IT
IS CRITICAL TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE ADEQUATE FUNDS AND I WOULD
SAY SUPPORTIVE REALLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT IS NEEDED IN A SPACE FOR
CONSTRUCTION WITH THAT I'M AND
ALSO WOULD ECHO THAT OPPORTUNITY
TO CURRENTLY OR WITH OTHER
PROGRAMS OFFERING YOU DE QUE BUT
WANTING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
REALLY HOMELESS DECK AND
UNDERSTAND IF THEY'D PROBABLY
HAVE TO SELL THE NEEDS AS WELL.
AND SAID THAT THAT THOSE FUNDS
WOULD BE ADDED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE ENOUGH YOU REALLY
ADDRESS. THE NEEDS. THANK YOU M.
FIVE QUESTIONS I'M GONNA GO TO
MIKE. TO THE SECOND. BUT I HAVE
SORT OF A- THIS. QUESTION OF
THE- OF FINE. THE THAT ACTUALLY
DOES HAS FOR HIM FOR. ACROSS THE
STATE AND THAT IS ABOUT. THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN BASIC K.
EIGHT SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN. THIS
PROGRAM AND- BECAUSE THE FUNDING
FOR THIS PROGRAM COMES THROUGH
THE FORMULA OR THE ALLOCATIONS
THAT BASIC AID SCHOOL DISTRICTS
DON'T GET. IT APPEARS THAT THE
EXPECTATION IS. THAT IF YOUR
BASIC EIGHT SCHOOL DISTRICT
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO FIND THIS OUT
OF YOUR OWN RESOURCES WHERE
EVERYBODY ELSE IS GETTING
SOMETHING IN THE FORMULA. TO DO
IT AND THE SAN LUIS COASTAL
DISTRICT IN SAN LUIS OBISPO IS
VERY UNIQUE THERE ARE BASIC
EIGHT SCHOOL DISTRICT. OUR BROAD
THEY ALSO HAVE THE DABBLE CANYON
NUCLEAR POWER PLANT IN THEIR
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE A PLUNGE IN
PROPERTY TAXES. OF 9210% THAT
WILL COME WHEN IT THE
COMMISSION'S MAYBE IN THREE OR
THREE AND A HALF YEARS. AND SO
ASKING THEM TO TAKE ON WHAT IS
THE EQUIVALENT OF 3% OF THEIR
TOTAL BUDGET FOR NEW PROGRAM
WITH NO REVENUE WITH A FISCAL
CLIFF COMING. IS A SCARY THING
AND SO I WONDERED IF YOU WOULD
ADDRESS WHAT THE SITUATION IS
BETWEEN BASIC EIGHT SCHOOLS IN
THIS PROGRAM AND- HOW THEY ARE
TO BE FUNDED TO IMPLEMENT THIS
PROGRAM. IN A GRANT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE A STAB AT ANSWERING
THAT- SO JUST. AS A REMINDER FOR
STATUTE TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN ISN'T AND ISN'T TO
BE CONSTRUED AS A NEW PROGRAM OR
IS OFFERING A HIGHER LEVEL OF
SERVICE. SO A DISTRICT THAT HAD
A KINDERGARTEN PROGRAM- BEFORE
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN WAS
CREATED SHOULD NOW BE PROVIDING
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN TO
ALL. AGE ELIGIBLE KIDS ON THE
TIMELINE THAT'S DELINEATED IN
STATUTE- IN THE STATE PROVIDES A
PORTION MEANT FOR THE STUDENTS
THROUGH THE L. CFF. THREE WHICH
BASIC AID DISTRICTS GET PROPERTY
TAX REVENUES. NO DISTRICTS GET
SPECIFIC TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN SET ASIDES AND
THAT'S NOT THE WAY YOU LOCAL
CONTROL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
WAS BUILT. AND BEFORE THIS MOST
RECENT BUDGET ACT ALL LGAS WERE
EXPECTED TO ENROLL STUDENTS
TURNING FIVE BETWEEN SEPTEMBER
SECOND AND DECEMBER SECOND. IN A
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAM SUBJECT TO THE RECEIPT
OF APPORTIONMENT FOR
APPORTIONMENT- FOR KIDS AND HE
K. SO. ELLIE IS A BE ENTITLED TO
THE FULL LC FIVE APPORTIONMENT
FOR ANY ADDITIONAL TEA CASE
STUDENTS BASED ON AGE
ELIGIBILITY TIMELINE THAT
SPECIFIED IN STATUTE- AND THE
STATUTE EXPANDING TKA I KEEP
THOSE REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
APPLICABLE SINCE THE CREATION OF
T. K. THE BECAUSE OF THIS- THERE
IS EXPECTATION THAT. ALL ELEAZAR
ARE EXPECTED TO OFFER-
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN TO ALL
AGE ALL OF THE ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS- AND THE- YOU KNOW IF
THEY HAVE A DROP AND IT'S
BASICALLY DISTRICTS THE DROP IN.
PROPERTY TAXES THAT YOU KNOW
DOES NOT STILL THERE ARE. YOU
KNOW I'LL SEE IF I **** IT THEN
THE STATE PROVIDES STATE TAXES
TO FILL THAT BUCKET OTHERWISE-
THE FUNDING FORMULA IS CREATED
SO THAT. YOU KNOW ALL DISTRICTS
AND- ALL ELLIE AS OUR OUR
PROVIDED ADEQUATE FUNDING TO
SERVE. THEIR STUDENTS FOR THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE PROVIDED.
WOMEN TO TRY. THAT WILL BIT
BURKE BECAUSE FIRST. I THE THING
THAT YOU THEY DROP OUT OF BASIC
BECAUSE OF LOS PROPERTY TAX THAN
SUBJECT TO THE FORMULA AND THE
FORMULA HELPS THEM. BUT INTEL
THAT HAPPENS. GIVEN WHAT YOU
JUST SAID. A NON BASIC EIGHT
SCHOOL DISTRICT WOULD GET CREDIT
FOR. THE ADDITIONAL STUDENTS DOT
COM BUT THE BASIC A DISTRICT
WARDEN IS THAT CORRECT. FOR THIS
IS THAT CHRIS FERGUSON SO
BASICALLY DISTRICTS WOULD GET
CREDIT TOWARD THOSE STUDENTS
THROUGH THE L. T. ABOUT YOUR
CORRECT THAT THAT ELSE YEP THAT
FOR THOSE JUST REFERRAL TO BE
FUNDED WITHIN THEIR EXISTING
PROPERTY TAX REVENUES IF THEY
REMAINED BASIC. AND TO MADE TO
TRANSLATE THAT IT BASICALLY
MEANS THEY ABSORB THE COST OF
THE ADDITIONAL STUDENTS IN PRE
K. THAT IS NOT ABSORBED THE SAME
WIFE YOUR NON BASIC A DISTRICT
AND IF IT IS ROUGHLY 3% OF THEIR
BUDGET. THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT
ABSORPTION. S. N. ON NOT. ARE
IGNORING THE FACT THEIR BASIC
FOR THAT THEY HAVE TAX REVENUES-
BOTTOM THAT ARE SIGNIFICANT BUT
HAVING SAID THAT WE'RE STILL
PUTTING SOMETHING ON THEM
WITHOUT GIVING THE MONEY TO DO.
AND IN THAT ONE PARTICULAR
DISTRICT ARE GONNA DROP OUT A
BASIC AGE AND THEY'RE GOING TO
BE IN A WORLD OF HURT THREE AND
A HALF YEARS SUBJECT BACK TO DO
IT NOW. AND THEN THEY DON'T GET
RELIEF ON THAN ROMAN AND TELL
D'APPLE PET CANYON POWER. ARE
APPOINT CLOSES IT THERE IN A
WORLD OF HURT OTHERWISE SO. THE
AGENCY TO ME THAT OF THE
EXPECTATION IS THE RITUAL AND
TAKE CARE OF IT BUT BUT- I THINK
LOADING A NEW PROGRAM ON TO THEM
AND NOT PAYING FOR SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO CONSIDER IN SOME
FORM. R. AND I'M JUST SPEAKING
TO ONE THEY'RE ONE AND. THE
INTERESTING THING IS THAT. IF
THE- ON SCHOOL ON BASE AID IT IS
JUST BASICALLY YOU GET THE BASIC
CATER FOR PROPERTY TAXES ARE SO
HIGH THAT YOUR WEALTHY DISTRICT
AND THEREFORE YOU DON'T GET THE
- V. OUR ALLOCATION TO A MOMENT.
AND THEIR DIFFERENT KINDS OF
BASIC GRADE SCHOOL DISTRICTS I
MEAN. I HAD ONE IN MY SENATE
DISTRICT. THAT IS A FARMWORKER
COMMUNITY IT IS A DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY IT IS A VERY SMALL
OVERWHELMING. NUMBER OF FREE AND
REDUCED MEALS IN THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICT BUT THERE'S A LOCKET
INSTALLATION INSIDE THE
BOUNDARIES OF THE DISTRICT THAT
WAS A HUGE PROPERTY TAX PAYER.
AND AS A RESULT. WITH THIS
DISTRICT THAT WAS- MAJORITY OF
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS WAS
CONSIDERED A BASIC A DISTRICT
EVERYBODY NORMALLY WOULD LOOK AT
IT IS RICH AND THERE ARE OTHERS
THAT JUST BARELY TRIP IN THE
BASIC AID AND SO ADDING A THREE
PERCENT. WHEN THAT HAPPENS IS
NOT A FAIR EXPECTATION AND SO. I
WOULD HOPE THAT SOMEBODY WOULD
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS BECAUSE OUR
GOAL IS TO GET THESE PROGRAMS
OFF THE GROUND IN A GOOD WAY AND
NOT HAVE A FIGHT ABOUT SCHOOL
FINANCE SO ANYWAY. POINT MADE
LET ME GO TO MY COLLEAGUES. OF
WHO. WOULD WANT TO ASK QUESTIONS
ABOUT. R. OKAY THEN START
SENATOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
THIS IS A VERY SO A PROPOSED- A
MY QUESTION THIS PROBABLY
PRIMARILY DIRECTED THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- IS WHEN
WE LOOK AT THE PRE K. AND
PRESCHOOL EXPANSION PROPOSALS IN
THE GOVERNOR. I THIS IS ONE TIME
FUNDING AND IS IT CORRECT THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TWO YEARS OF
FUNDING. I GUESS IS MEANT TO
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR A TWO YEAR
EXPANSION OF T. K. AND A TWO
YEAR EXPANSION PRESCHOOL AM I
READING THAT CORRECTLY. SO JUST
TO CLARIFY THANK YOU KNOW
THERE'S A FOUR YEAR PHASE AND
OKAY ON THE EXPANSION OF
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN AND AS
THE DATE RANGES OR INCREASE THE
FUNDING IT IS BUILT INTO ELSE
YEP AB ONE ONGOING BASED- SO
THIS IS IT SO HOW MUCH IS IT.
THIS IS AN ONGOING EXPENSE FOR
THEM. YES OKAY SO WHEN WE'RE
TALKING OF THE SIX HUNDRED
THIRTY NINE MILLION WHAT IS WHAT
IS THAT FOR THAT'S JUST TO HELP
EACH. WITH THE EXPANSION. YES
THAT IS TRUE. SUPPORT THE
INCREMENTAL- EXPANSION IN THE
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE FISCAL
YEAR. WE BELIEVE THAT OVER THE
FOUR YEAR PERIOD THAT AMOUNT.
AND THAT REVENGE WILL INCREASE
TO A TOTAL OF THREE POINT
ROUGHLY THREE BILLION THREE
POINT ONE BILLION ON GOING. TO
SUPPORT FULL IMPLEMENTATION- IN
IN FUTURE YEARS ONCE IT'S FULLY
IMPLEMENTED SO I APOLOGIZE IF I
MISSED THIS BUT LIKE WHAT IS THE
ACTUAL ONGOING COMMITMENT AND
YOU KNOW ASSUMING THAT SOUP TO
NUTS WHEAT WE'RE SUCCESS WITH
THIS EXPANSION IS SIX HUNDRED
THIRTY NINE MILLION. THAT IS
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR FOR KI
K- IS ENOUGH IS THE RIGHT
AMOUNT. HOW MUCH ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT AN ON GOING BASIS
ANNUALIZED. YEAH YOU'RE A- ONCE
WE GET THE TWENTY TWENTY FIRST
YEAR WHEN THAT THE PROGRAM IS
FULLY IMPLEMENTED. WE WOULD
EXPECT THE GUARANTEED TO BE
REVENGE RABBI ROUGHLY THREE
POINT ONE BILLION. TO SUPPORT
THE FULL IMPLEMENTATION OF AND
UNIVERSAL ACCESS TO A
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN I AM I
UNDERSTAND THEY ARE USING THREE
POINT ONE BILLION TOTAL FOR K.
THROUGH TWELVE OR THREE POINT
ONE BILLION JUST FOR THE PRE K.
THIRTY K. PIECE. JUST FOR THE G.
CARE EXPANSION OKAY SO THREE
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
OKAY. AND THEN I GUESS THE
OBVIOUS QUESTION IS A YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY I FAVOUR HE- EXPANSION
AND HE CAN UNIVERSAL T. K. IT-
YOU KNOW AS SOMEONE WHO ACTUALLY
HAS A SON IN KINDERGARTEN I KNOW
HOW VALUABLE THAT IS AND- HAVING
HAD THAT T. K. EXPERIENCE. WAS
VERY IMPORTANT FOR HIS
DEVELOPMENT. BUT IS THIS
SOMETHING WHERE THERE ARE
CONCERNS THAT IF THE BUDGET IF I
REVENUE START TO DECLINE YOU
KNOW AS THEY DO- THAT. WE MIGHT
BE SORT OF OVER EXTENDING
OURSELVES. THE SEARCH. AT THIS
TIME OF OUR MULTI YOUR
PROJECTION WE DON'T SEE THAT
OCCURRING OKAY- BUT- YOU KNOW
THAT THAT'S CERTAINLY A
POSSIBILITY THAT WE WOULD HAVE
TO DEAL WITH IF AND WHEN THAT
SITUATION WERE TO OCCUR. AND
THEN I GUESS IT IS A FOLLOW UP
YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT PRESCHOOL
EXPANSION. YOU KNOW IDEALLY WE
HAVE. UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL IN
UNIVERSAL TAKE A BIT YOU KNOW
FOR A LOT OF FAMILIES I'VE HEARD
THE COMPLAINT THAT. YOU YOU KNOW
GET AN EXPANSION OF T. K. BY
ITSELF. MAY NOT HELP A LOT OF
FAMILIES WHO OFTEN JUST NEED
THE- THE COVERAGE OF THEIR
CHILDREN THAT THEY NEED THE
CHILD CARE- AND SO TO THE EXTENT
THAT. YOU KNOW. LET'S JUST
ASSUME A UNIVERSE IN WHICH WE
DON'T HAVE. ENOUGH FUNDS TO
COVER BOTH. A UNIVERSAL PRE K.
R. KI K. I. AND WE AND ALSO
SOMETHING LIKE UNIVERSAL
EXPANSION PRESCHOOL ACCESS. I IS
THERE A SENSE THAT ONE OF THESE
IS GOING TO BE PRIORITIZED OVER
THE OTHER- IT LOOKS LIKE WE'RE
PRIORITIZING KEY K. BUT WHAT. IS
THAT. IS THAT CHOICE SOMETHING
THAT WAS INTENTIONAL AND I
GUESS. THE FOLLOW UP QUESTION IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT THAT YOU
WOULD. HAVE A RATIONALE FOR WHAT
Y. PREFERENCE TKO OVER PRESCHOOL
OR VICE VERSA. YOU KNOW I WOULD
SAY THAT- FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PERSPECTIVE WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT A MIX
DELIVERY SYSTEM- SO WAIT WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT YOU KNOW FOR
OUR PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS WILL
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT. EXTENDED
LEARNING AN OPPORTUNITY
PROGRAMS- AS WELL AS OUR
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAMS AND WE DEFINITELY
ENCOURAGE DISTRICTS TO YOU. GO
AHEAD AND BREAK THOSE PROGRAMS
TOGETHER- IN A WAY THAT THAT
PROVIDES PARENTS- WITH THE
CHOICE. OF FOR THEIR CHILDREN SO
THAT THEY THEY CAN BEST CHOOSE
THE PROGRAM THAT THEY THINK WILL
WORK BEST FOR THEIR SITUATION
AND THEIR CHILD. RIGHT NOW I
GUESS I GUESS MY QUESTION IS A
LITTLE DIFFERENT WHICH IS YOU
KNOW THAT THAT'S- LIKE RIGHT NOW
WE'RE PLANTING THE SEEDS FOR
POTENTIALLY UNIVERSAL T. K. AND
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL. RITE AID
AND IF THAT'S A FAIR WAY TO
DESCRIBE IT- I END THAT WORKS AS
LONG AS WE HAVE ENOUGH FUNDING
TO DO THAT BUT SHOULD WE COME TO
A POINT WHERE MAYBE. THE FUNDING
OUR REVENUES TAKE A DIFFERENT
ROUTE NINETY FUNDS TAKE A DIP.
AND WE HAVE TO MAKE A CHOICE-
YOU KNOW DEBBIE'S HAVE YOU
THOUGHT THROUGH SORT OF. WHETHER
THERE'S A PREFERENCE FOR ONE OR
THE OTHER AND WHY. YEAH I
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO PROVIDE YOU
WITH WITH DETAIL ON WHAT A
PREFERENCE MIGHT BE IN THE
FUTURE- BECAUSE WE DON'T PREDICT
THAT AT THIS TIME- AND CERTAINLY
WE WOULD HAVE TO. YOU KNOW
ENGAGED THE LEGISLATURE IN YOUR-
PERSPECTIVE STOPS IN A
CONVERSATION. SHOULD THAT
SITUATION OCCURRED. ON IT- LA-
DO YOU HAVE ANY THOUGHTS ON THIS. I'M A BIG I THINK IF YOU'LL
GET INSIDE IS YOUR ARE WITH THE
TIMING OF IT MATTERS AND THE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS BUT I WOULD
SAY THAT- YOU KNOW. WHEN TICKETS
IMPLEMENTED T. K. IS JUST PART
OF ALTHEA- AND SO IF YOUR GOING
TO GET TO THAT POINT I DON'T I
THINK. THE IDEA THAT YOU COULD
JUST SORT OF SAYING WE'RE NOT
GOING TO FUND THESE. THESE
CHILDREN ANYMORE WELL
ESSENTIALLY SAYING THAT YOU'RE
NOT GONNA FIND A GROUP OF- GREAT
EXIST IS UNLIKELY SO NOW I WOULD
SAY THAT IF WE DO IN THE IN A
RECESSION BUT THE TWO CHOICES
THAT YOU HAVE ARE. FOR EXAMPLE
IF THERE ARE THEY WERE NOT OING
TO PROVIDE WILL OFFER OF THE FF
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE REDUCTIONS
THAT WOULD BE A- BECAUSE THE
MARKETS ON THE SHOULD NOT
NECESSARILY FOCUS ON ONE
PARTICULAR AREA. WHERE MORE IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE BUT THESE TWO
KIND OF PLACES WHERE YOU HAVE TO
GO TO MAKE REDUCTIONS OF
MUSTARD. I AS I SAY I TELL YOU
WHAT YOU'RE SAYIG IS THAT. THE
EXPANSION ANTI K. WILL WILL
BASICALLY BAITED AND WILL HAVE
NO CHOICE BUT IT'S IT'LL
ESSENTIALLY. SHOULD WE HAVE
BUDGET ISSUES DOWN THE LINE IT
WILL BE A CHOICE BETWEEN TWO K.
AND PRESCHOOL IT IT'LL BE A
CHOICE BETWEEN THE QUALITY OF
CARE- PRETTY K. THROUGH TWELVE
EDUCATION BECAUSE OF THE-
WHETHER WE PROVIDE PRESCHOOL AND
CHILDCARE. THANK THE END OF
VARIOUS THANK YOU AND THEN- A
SEPARATE LINE OF QUESTIONING I
I'VE I'VE BEEN TOLD THE TRUTH
AND I THINK THIS CAME UP EARLIER
OP FACILITIES- ARE A BARRIER TO
EXPANDING TEAK IN THE SHORT RUN-
DOES IT IS THERE ANY THOUGHT PUT
TO PERHAPS- ALLOWING AT LEAST AN
INTERIM. A DIFFERENT ELEAZAR
POTENTIALLY- DEPUTIZE THE
EXPANSION EIGHTY K. TO SUB
PRESCHOOLS OR OTHERWISE I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF PRIVATE
PRESCHOOLS IN MY- IN MY
DISTRICT. ARE THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY BE USED FOR THAT
PURPOSE- AT LEAST TEMPORARILY OR
SOMETHING LIKE PERHAPS A- I. T.
K. PROGRAM IS OVERSEEN BY THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT- IF THAT'S AN
ISSUE IN SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IS THAT IS THAT SOMETHING THAT
WOULD BE A POTENTIALLY SOLUTION
. FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE WE
CERTAINLY ENCOURAGE OUR
PROVIDERS TO WORK WITH OUR OUR
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO
WORK WITH OUR PRESCHOOL
PROVIDERS ON THAT SAID THERE ARE
DIFFERENCES IN THE STANDARDS FOR
FACILITIES OR PRIVATE PROVIDER
VERSES- DODD AND ELEAZAR
FACILITIES FOR EXAMPLE OR RTK
FACILITIES ARE GOING TO BE BUILT
AT CENTER. I MENTIONED EARLIER-
CHIU THE FIELD ACTUALLY ENTERED
SO IT YEAH IT'S DEFINITELY A
HIGHER CONSTRUCTION STANDARDS-
ON OUR TRADITIONAL SCHOOL A
CLASSROOM. THANK YOU AND THEN I
GUESS MY LAST QUESTION- IN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR YOUR POINT HERE IS
AS DIRECTED TO THE PERSON FROM
CYPRESS SCHOOL DISTRICT-
WELCOME- THANK YOU FOR
REPRESENTING ORANGE COUNTY AND I
I'VE I'M LOOKING FOR YOUR NAME
RIGHT NOW AND IT'S- I'M SORRY
MISS TAYLOR- MAYBE I WAS ONE IF
YOU COULD SPEAK TO. YOU KNOW
SORT OF SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
YOU MIGHT SEE IN. BOTH OF THESE
PROPOSALS AND- YOU KNOW ANY
INSIGHTS YOU MIGHT HAVE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. THANK YOU THIS
DANNY TAYLOR. AND YOU KNOW. WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT AND I HEARD
EVERYTHING AND I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE- EVERYBODY'S EFFORTS
AND SUCH THIS IS A REMARKABLE
OPPORTUNITY. WHEN IT COMES TO
THE FACILITIES AND HEARING
EVERYTHING I SAID I THINK
THERE'S- THERE'S NO BATHROOMS I
MEAN QUITE FRANKLY. AND YOU KNOW
YES WE ARE IN A DECLINING.
PARTICULARLY IN MY DISTRICT YOU
KNOW- BUT YET BUT THERE ARE
THERE ARE NOT THE BATHROOMS
THERE'S NOTHING I NEED A LIFE.
AND YOU KNOW I THE PREVIOUS
KINDERGARTEN AND PRESCHOOL
TEACHER YOU KNOW TEACHER YEAH
YOU GO TO SIT ON THIS CHAIR
THOUGHT THE WHOLE. LONG FALL.
BUT YET FOR THOSE LITTLE ONES
THAT'S WHAT THEY NEED RIGHT AND
SO THOSE ARE THE- BIGGEST
CHALLENGES I MET WITH MY
DIRECTOR UP MY LAST NIGHT AND
THAT WAS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
STRUGGLES AS WE'RE LOOKING. HOW
ARE WE GOING TO INTEGRATE
PARTICULARLY WITH OUR STUDENTS
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS. HOW ARE WE
GOING TO. MAKE URE WE HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM. TO
ADDRESS. AND THEIR INTEGRATION
WE'RE LOOKING AT HOW AM I GOING
TO RE WRITE MY CSP PROGRAM. SO
THAT WE CAN FULLY INTEGRATE. AND
BECAUSE WE KNOW IT'S THE RIGHT.
THING I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
AND- LOSSING. YOU KNOW. DEAN AND
HE TALKED ABOUT- THE DAY. THAT
IS BECAUSE- OUT- AND NEEDING AND
IN A HEARD FROM D. E. COMMITTEE
THAT EGGS- WITHOUT IT WE WOULD
HAVE HE WOULD HAVE. OVER
FOURTEEN HUNDRED WAIVERS HE
WOULD HAVE TO RIGHT. BUT THERE
ARE SOME UNIQUE NEEDS I'M TO
HAVE A SEAMLESS PROGRAM BETWEEN
THE TWO YES. HE AND THE SCHOOL
AGE PROGRAM- AND SO IF TRYING TO
PUT ALL THESE PIECES TOGETHER AS
YOU HEARD YOU KNOW ON FEBRUARY
SEVENTEENTH THE GUIDANCE WAS PUT
OUT. AND SO JUST TO READ THROUGH
THATYOU KNOW I SHARED.
LITERALLY DURING THE OMICRON YOU
KNOW WE WAKE UP TO SERVICES
EDUCATOR- OFFICE STAFF WHAT IS
IT TODAY. AND WE'RE JUST ALL
COMING UP FOR AIR AND TRYING TO
READ THROUGH AND GET EVERYTHING
YOU KNOW AND THERE'S THE
EXPANDED LEARNING PLAN YOU KNOW
THAT THE CHANGES TO THE L. SHOP-
YOU KNOW I CAN PROP STARK I MEAN
I CAN BROUGHT. ALL THESE
ACRONYMS. AND DOING ALL THAT SO
MAKE SURE WE'RE WE'RE ADDRESSING
YOU KNOW THE STAFF. HERE TESTING
THE- CHAIR WHO HAS AN ANTI
ACRONYM CAMPAIGN. BECAUSE WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE THE PLAYOFFS.
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHEN WE HAVE GUESTS
CONVERSATION. EVERYBODY'S BEEN
STARING AT ME IN THE HEARING
ROOM WONDERING WHEN I WAS GOING
TO SAY SO YEAH. THE LOCAL
CONTROL AND ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN
YOU KNOW THERE'S THERE WAS NEW
THERE WAS A NEW PLAN FOR THAT WE
HAVE THE- UNIVERSAL. AND YOU K.
WHATEVER THE UNIVERSEPRESCHOOL. GARDEN PLAN YOU KNOW A I JUST
TRYING TO UP TO A I GO WITH YOU
CHAIR RIGHT THERE YEAH YOU GO.
WERE XP LEARN OPPORTUNITIES THE
L. LOCAL. WE NEED TO DO ALL THE
THESE. IN A VERY FOUGHT PURPOSE
MAY. WAY AND CLOVEN ALL TO GET
TO THESE ROBOTS PURPOSE AND I
KNOW I AND- MR FERGUSON KNOW
TALK ABOUT BEING ABLE TO WORK
WITH OUR EDUCATIONAL PARTNERS.
IN MY LOCAL AREA I'M STILL
GRAPPLING TO UNDERSTAND THESE IN
A MEANINGFUL WAY SO THAT I CAN
HAVE MEANINGFUL CONVERSATIONS
AND I DON'T WANT TO TAKE AWAY
FROM CD OR MY COUNTY OFFICE THAT
HE'S IN COURT TRYING TO PROVIDE
ME WITH THE INFORMATION. BUT IN
MY LOCAL DISTRICT I'M SMALL YOU
KNOW I I'M ONE PERSON WHO'S
TRYING TO ATTEND ALL THE ZONES
SOMETIMES THEY HAPPEN
SIMULTANEOUSLY SO THAT I'M
TRYING TO READ THROUGH ALL THE
CONTACT. THEY'RE WONDERFUL
RESOURCES THERE THEY'RE SUPER
SUPPORTIVE THEY RESPOND TO ME.
BUT I CAN ONLY DO SO MUCH.
HUMANLY POSSIBLE RIGHT NOW MY
BIGGEST GOAL IS KEEPING
EVERYTHING COPE IT AWAY FROM MY
STUDENTS MAKING SURE THAT
THEY'RE BEING EDUCATED IN THE
MOST APPROPRIATE ATMOSPHERE-
WHILE TRYING TO MANAGE
EVERYTHING THAT'S COMING TO ME
AND YOU KNOW LOGISTICALLY AND
CONTENT WEISS. AS I MOVE FORWARD
. FEBRUARY SEVENTEENTH TWO A
JUNE PLAN IS NOT A LOT OF TIME.
WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO ENGAGE AND
THEN GRAPPLE WITH DO I HAVE
BATHROOMS DO I HAVE PLAYSPACE DO
I HAVE STAFF YOU KNOW ALL OF
THOSE THINGS. EIGHT IMMENSE
AMOUNT OF TIME WHEN YOU'RE
TRYING TO DEAL WITH JUST ALSO
THE BUSINESS OF EDUCATING
CHILDREN. I APPRECIATE THAT AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS TAYLOR
I DON'T I DON'T REPRESENT CYPRUS
I'M JUST A LITTLE BIT- THE EAST
YOU BUT- APPRECIATE YOUR LOCAL
ORANGE COUNTY PERSPECTIVE
NONETHELESS AND- MY KIDS ARE-
LEVIN NINE AND SIX SO IIT'S
BEEN AWHILE SINCE THEY WERE
DOING THE POTTY TRAINING THING
BUT AS YOU'RE TALKING IT IT
BROUGHT ME BACK TO THAT TIME AND
I DO REMEMBER THOSE LITTLE
BATHROOMS AND- GENERALLY YES
THERE IS A LOT. OF WORK THAT
NEEDS TO GO INTO GETTING KIDS
READY FOR OTHER TRADITIONAL K.
THROUGH TWELVE SAID INCLUDING
POTTY TRAINING- YEAH BUT YOU
KNOW IT AND LETTERS AND NUMBERS
AND SO- I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONCERNS AND SO I CERTAINLY
SUPPORT THE GOALS OF- YOU KNOW
EXPANDING T. K. UNIVERSAL T. K.
OF PRESCHOOL- BUT I THINK YOU
RAISE SOME IMPORTANT POINTS THAT
WE NEED TO GET RIGHT SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- SENATOR OCHO BOAT. NO QUESTIONS BUT JUST COMMENTS
I JUST WHEN I REALLY COMMEND MY
COLLEAGUES FOR ASKING REALLY
POINTING QUESTIONS AND VERY
RELEVANT THAT I ABSOLUTELY
CONCUR WITH FIVE WITH BOTH OF
YOU SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR.
BRINGING THOSE FOURTH. THEN LET
ME ASK ONE CLOSING QUESTION-
BECAUSE- A JENNIFER HICKS THE
ASSISTANT SUPERINTENDENT. ARE
REALLY FOCUSED ON THE ISSUE OF A
MIX DELIVERY MODEL AND WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE INTO ANOTHER ITEM
IN A MOMENT THAT'S RELATED SO.
WE HAVE CHILD CARE PRE K. E. R-
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN WE
HAVE A MIX AND- THE REFERENCE
WAS MADE TO A MIX DELIVERY MODEL
AND SHE ACTUALLY DID THE ON THE
GROUND DESCRIPTION OF SOMEBODY
WALKING ABOUT ACROSS THE
PLAYGROUND FROM ONE TO ANOTHER-
HOW ARE WE- SORT OF SUPPORTING
THE FLEXIBILITY OF LOCAL
DISTRICTS TO DO THE NEXT-
DELIVERY MODEL. I MEAN IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT WERE JUST FORCING
THEM TO FIGURE OUT IS THERE
SOMETHING WE'RE DOING ITS
INCENTIVES HOWEVER WE TRY TO
INTEGRATE THESE TOGETHER AND I
DON'T KNOW WHO FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WOULD LIKE
TO TAKE A- STAB AT THE. RIGHT I
CAN TAKE THE LEAD ON THAT ONE I
THANK GOD CERTAINLY WE PROVIDED
SOME ASSISTANCE IN ONE OF OUR
LITERACY PROPOSALS AS WELL AS- A
YOU KNOW FIFTY MILLION OF THE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE
INCLUSIVE EARLY EDUCATION
EXPANSION. OF PROGRAMS TO
PROVIDE THE TYPE OF BLENDING AND
BRAIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND GUIDANCE TO DISTRICTS. I
NEED TO OPERATE MULTIPLE
PROGRAMS IN YOU KNOW AN
INTEGRATED FASHION- TO SERVEAND
MEET THE NEEDS OF THEIR STUDENTS
FOR EXMPLE YOU COULD HAVE A
DISTRICT. THAT PROVIDES SIDE YOU
KNOW HOW STATE PROGRAM THROUGH
THEIR TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN. UTILIZES
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM CONTRACT TO SUPPORT THE-
OF THE OTHER HALF OF THE SCHOOL
DAY AND THEN ULTIMATELY LINKS
INTO THEIR EXTENDED BURNING
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM TO PROVIDE.
YOU KNOW AN EXTENDED DAY OF
COVERAGE OF FOR THAT SAME
STUDENTS FOR YOU CAN BLEND AND
BRAID. THESE MULTIPLE PROGRAMS
TOGETHER- USING THAT MAKES
DELIVERY SYSTEM WOULD CERTAINLY
ENCOURAGE DISTRICTS TO DO THAT
AND ARE WORKING WITH THE.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
PRIVATE. TO TRY PROVIDE THAT
GUIDANCE CHIU- THE FIELD RIGHT
NOW. I'M SURE TO COME. APPROACH
WE ALSO UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW IT'S
BEEN MENTIONED MANY TIMES
THEY'RE STRAPPING ISSUES ARE YOU
KNOW PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS IS AN
ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
HIGH NEED AREAS IN OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM- YOU KNOW
TRYING TO CREATE BETTER
PIPELINES IN THESE AREAS OF OUR
HIGH SCHOOLS. LEADING INTO
HIGHER EDUCATION THAT ULTIMATELY
LEAD TO. A YOU KNOW HOW COMES
AND STAFFING OPPORTUNITIES. FOR
OUR STUDENTS- AND EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND ECONOMIC
MOBILITY FOR STUDENTS BUT WE
WERE TRYING TO TAKE A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO MEET
THE NEEDS AND LET ME JUST MAYBE
GIVE A CHANCE FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION COMMENT ON THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR AND OF A
MARKETING DEPARTMENT OF BAD
DUDES YOU BUILD UP WITH MR
PERSON JUST SHARED. WE ALSO
ECEIVED A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION IN THIS GREAT YOUR
PROJECT FOR EXPANSION OF OUR
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM. AND BACK OR IF THEY OR
REQUEST FOR FUNDING APPLICATION
WAS JUST POSTED YESTERDAY AND
FROM THAT WE HOPE TO EXPAND THE
NUMBER. A THREE STILL PRESS. BUT
AS PART OF THAT. FREE PROGRAM
HE'S AND THEN ALSO THE
DEPARTMENT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE REALLY EMPHASIZED IS
THAT MAKES DELIVERY. ALL OF OUR
GUIDANCE BUT THE PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION TEMPLATE AS WELL
AS THAT GUIDANCE THAT WAS
RECENTLY RELEASED WE HAVE A LOT
OF INFORMATION ON. THE PARTNERS
IN YOUR SYSTEM WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN TO BE MIXED THE LIBRARY AND
HOW YOU CAN LAYER AND WORK
TOGETHER. ACROSS HEAD START
STATE PRESCHOOL OTHER PRIVATE
PRE K. PROGRAM AND NOT EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES. WE ALSO
IN THAT PLANNING TEMPLATE
CREATED SOME SPACE FOR THEM TO
ACTUALLY INCLUDE THAT MAKES
DELIVERY AND TO. INTERACT ACROSS
THE PLAN THAT THEY HAVE TO DO
FOR THE EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAMS. AND VERY
FEW KEY K. SO THAT INTEGRATION
THAT IS SO CRITICAL AS WE LOOK
AT ALL OF THESE HE SAID. REALLY
STARTS TO COME TOGETHER IN THEIR
PLANS. INTENTIONALLY HELLO I
DIDN'T TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE OUR
WEBINARS. AND THE ACTUAL PLAN.
DOCUMENTS AND OUT. K. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH N. AS- WEEK GO ON FOR
A WHILE BUT HAVE DRILL DOWN ON
SOME OF THE MAJOR ISSUES HERE.
AND EXPRESSED OUR CONCERNS AND
REALLY HOPE THAT AS WE MOVE
TOWARDS MAY REVISE THERE'S A FEW
OF THESE ISSUES WE MIGHT NEED TO
ADDRESS AND JUST LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
TO DO THAT. LET ME THANK ALL OUR
PANELISTS- NOT JUST FROM THE
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES BUT AND
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT THAT
OFFER THE LOCAL PERSPECTIVE WE
REALLY APPRECIATE. YOU HAVING
BEEN WITH US TODAY THAT WAS VERY
HELPFUL. AND ALL THESE ITEMS FOR
THE UNINITIATED OR HELD OPEN SO
THAT WE WILL. COME BACK TO THEM.
IN THE SPRING WHEN THE REVENUES
ARE CLEAR AND SOME ADDITIONAL
WORK HAS BEEN DONE ON. WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO
WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM ELIGIBILITY
CHANGES. OUR PANEL IS EDGAR
CABRAL FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE JODI LIEBERMAN
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AND VIRGINIA EARLY THE EDUCATION
MINISTER RIGHT ADMINISTRATOR FOR
EARLY EDUCATION DIVISION THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WILL
TAKE THE PANELISTS IN THAT
ORDER. AND WILL WELCOME BACK MR
CABRAL TO THE COMMITTEE. IN
EVERY ROLE AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I'M I THINK THE
WE CAN TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE PIZZA BUT- THE GOVERNOR'S-
PROPOSAL HERE BUT I'LL JUST
HIGHLIGHT THAT. BIG PIECES HERE
FIRST IS THE REQUIREMENT THAT-
10% OF CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES AND STATE PRESCHOOL
ARE- BUT OUR 10% OF CHILDREN AND
HOLDS THE PRESCHOOL ARE OUR
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES. I'M
THE PROPOSAL ALSO COMES WITH AN
ASSOCIATED INCREASE OF FUNDING-
FOR SERVING CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES. THERE'S ALSO ARE.
IN ADDITION PROPOSAL TO OUR FOR
WHAT'S CALLED TWENTY FOUR MY
ELIGIBILITY IS ONCE A- FAMILY
BEEN DEEMED ELIGIBLE FOR STATE
PRESCHOOL THAT. ARE THEY ARE NOT
THEY DON'T NEED TO CONFIRM THAT
ALL THE BODY GET OR OR FOR
SUBMIT NEW PAPERWORK WITH.
WITHIN THE NEXT TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS. AND THEN FINALLY THERE'S
A PROPOSAL TO- TO ALLOW FREE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS TO SERVE TWO
YEAR OLD. I'M I THINK IN OUR OUR
OVERALL COMMENTED BIG WITH THAT
WE DO THINK- IS. TRYING TO SERVE
ADDITIONAL CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES AS THE NORM
IMPORTANT GOAL OF THE BIG- I
THINK THAT THEY- PROPOSAL MAKES
OF MEDWAY. ROAD WOULD BE SOME TO
WHAT IS IN THE HEAD START
PROGRAM BUT THE FEDERAL. BUT
THERE'S LOW INCOME- THREE AND
FOUR YEAR OLDS AND WE THINK
THAT. THAT BUT BUT BUT THE GOOD
START POINT FOR TO SERVE
ADDITIONAL FIVE CHILDREN. OF THE
STATE OF THE STORE BLACK
COMPARED THE REST OF THE NATION
IN TERMS OF. ACCESS REQUESTED
PROGRAMS FOR PRESCHOOL AGE KIDS-
I'M SO FOR EXAMPLE THERE'S ONE
METRIC THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT COLLECTS WHICH IS. A
SHARE OF THREE TO FIVE YEAR OLDS
WITH DISABILITIES THAT ATTEND A
REGULAR EARLY CHILDHOOD PROGRAM
FOR AT LEAST TEN HOURS A WEEK
BUT AFTER THE MULTIPLE BUTTONS
WE AT LEAST TEN HOURS A WEEK OF.
BEING IN A SORT OF MORE FORMAL
REGULAR CLASSROOM. IN CALIFORNIA
IT'S ONLY 27% OF THREE TO FIVE
YEAR OLDS PRESENT IN THIS DODD
NATION MORE BROADLY IT'S 56%
CALIFORNIA'S MUCH MUCH WORSE
THAN THAT AND THEN THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY- AND IN THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM ITS OFFICES
THE WORK WE HAD RELATIVELY LOW
SHARES. UP 4% OF CHILDREN IN IN
TWENTY NINETEEN WHAT BOLD WITH
WITH DISABILITIES UNTIL WE DO
THE TAKING ADDITIONAL ACTIONS
MAKE SENSE. I'M WE WILL ALSO
NOTE THAT DOES THE EXPANSION OF
TRADITIONAL CONVERTIBLE WILL
ALSO LIKELY INCREASE ACCESS- TO
PROGRAMS WHEN WE TALKED TO.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS ABOUT HOW WE CAN
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF A FOUR
YEAR OLDS. WHO HAVE ACCESS TO A
TO A CONCERT PROGRAM ONE OF THE
PRIMARY CONCERN THEY MENTIONED
WAS. THAT THEY DIDN'T HAVE
ACCESS TO A PROGRAM FROM
DISTRICTS DON'T RUN THEIR OWN
STATE. PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS FOR
SOME SO THEY DON'T HAVE A PLACE-
A PROGRAM RUNS. GRADING HE CAME
ACROSS THE STATE WILL HELP IN
THAT THEIR- SETTINGS HONORABLY.
FOR YEAR OLDS. ARE WE DO NOT
THAT. WITH THAT THE PERCENT OF.
IS A REASONABLE POINT BUT WE DO
THINK THE LEGISLATURE WANT TO
RE. THE IN A FEW YEARS. GIVEN
THE SIGNAL THING ABOUT ARE
OCCURRING. IG OF. KINDERGARTEN
YOU KNOW ONCE HE CAME. EXPANDED
WE WOULD X. IT TO BE A- STAR
PROGRAM AT THE PRESCHOOL FOLKS.
WHAT WHAT- APPLE LOOKS LIKE IN
THE KIND OF THAT IF THAT ARE BIG
. PROGRAM WITH A- WHAT WE THINK
MAYBE A REASON. REQUIREMENT BE
DRIVES THE SHOW CHILDREN
DISABILITY THAT IN IN THE PRIEST
- ALSO THE EXTENT THAT PROVIDERS
. DIFFICULT ABOUT THIS FOR.
BELOW THAT YOU WANT TO CONSIDER
WAYS TO. THE FROM. TO ADDRESS
THOSE. AND SORT OF AND
EVERYTHING. THAT WOULD IMPORTANT
TO MONITOR ALL THE TIME. I'M
WITH TO THE TWENTY FOUR MONTH
OLD BELIEVE. WE DIRECTOR
ADOPTING PROPOSED- THERE ARE
PROVIDERS IN SEVERAL. THAT HAVE
BEEN GROW. THROUGH STATUTE WHAT
THE BILITY FROM THIRD PARTIES.
MANY OF THE TWENTY FIVE ARE ABLE
TWENTY FOUR MONTH OLD ABILITY
UNDER- FOR. IS THE REPUBLIC.
HEALTH INSURER CAN ARE KNOWS.
AND ARE. THAT WOULD- WE DO HAVE
SOME COST RECOMMENDING CAUTION
ON THIS ISSUE AND WE WONDER IF
THIS MIGHT BE SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO WAIT.
FOR A FEW MORE YEARS AFTER
SEEING HOW IMPLEMENTATION OF-
THESE PROGRAMS OCCURS- DID
DEFINITELY WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR
PROVIDER WHO MAYBE LIFE HAVING
MORE DIFFICULTY WITH SERVING ALL
OF THE KIDS ARE. FOR ME OUR OUR
YOUR BILL AND ALL SLOTS FIFTY
HAVE A LOT OF WILL TO PGA-
CRITICAL FOR THOSE WHO ALSO
OPERATE AS A- CHOPPER. WHICH IS
A TRUCK PROGRAM THAT THE STATE
FROM. THAT SERVICE CONSERVE INTO
AND TODDLERS. BOTH PROGRAMS MY
THIS MY BE BENEFITS FOR THEM.%
BUT THERE ARE SOME ADMIN CHAU-
IF NOT AS EASY AS A SORT
STARTING TO YOUR THEM- FIRST OF
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT. INSTEAD
RATIO SO YOU NEED TWICE AS MANY
ADULTS. PER CHILD- IN A BRIDGE
YEAR OLD AND A FOUR OLD UNDER
THE STUDENTS. THIS WOULD REQUIRE
PROVIDERS TO GO OUT AND HIRE
MORE STAFF RIGHT NOW HAS BEEN IS
A CHALLENGE GIVEN SPECTER
SHORTAGES. BUT ALSO IN MY TO
MODIFY THE FACILITIES ARE. ONCE
EXAMPLE IS. AT YOU'RE A TWO YEAR
OLDIN THE TO HAVE. A DIAPER TO
SPEECH TO DEAL WITH- JIM DIAPERS
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DEAL WITH.
FOUR YEAR OLD. AND SO YOU MAY
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT FOR YOUR
FACILITY ARE LOADED- A MODIFIED
TO THEIR PER. NEEDS OF GIVEN
THOSE CHANGES WE I THINK THIS
MIGHT BE FOR OF A- BY WANT TO DO
IN THE FUTURE. ABILITY TO ADD
NEW REQUIREMENTS TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO INCLUSIVE PRESCHOOL
ENVIRONMENTS. THE ADMINISTRATION
RECOGNIZES THAT CHILDREN
DISABILITIES HAVE BETTER LONG
TERM OUTCOMES WHEN THOSE
DISABILITIES ARE IDENTIFIED
EARLY AND INTERVENTIONS BEGIN AT
A YOUNG AGE. HOWEVER WHILE ABOUT
12% OF STUDENT IN PUBLIC CASE
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS STATEWIDE
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED DISABILITY
ONLY ABOUT 4% OF STUDENTS AND
STATE PRESCHOOL. OUR CHILDREN
WITH DISABILITIES. MEANWHILE THE
FEDERAL HEAD START PROGRAM
REQUIRES ENROLLMENT INCLUDE AT
LEAST 10% OF STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. TO INCREASE ACCESS
TO INCLUSIVE PRESCHOOL
ENVIRONMENTS AND TO ALIGN WITH
HEAD START BUT IT REQUIRES STATE
PRESCHOOL CONTRACTORS TO
MAINTAIN ENROLLMENT OF AT LEAST
10% STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
TO PROVIDE CONTRACTORS WITH THE
FUNDS NECESSARY TO SERVE A DISH
ADDITIONAL STUDENTS WITH
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT NEEDS.
THE BUDGET PROVIDES A HUNDRED
NINETY SEVEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND. A HUNDRED AND TEN POINT
SIX MILLION GENERAL FUND TO
INCREASE ADJUSTMENT FACTORS FOR
THE STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE MORE SUPPORT TO STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES. AND DAHLE
LANGUAGE LEARNERS. AS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED- THE BUDGET PROPOSES
SEVERAL CHANGES TO ELIGIBILITY
TO EXPAND ACCESS TO STATE
PRESCHOOL. FIRST THE BUDGET
INCLUDES CATEGORICAL ELIGIBILITY
AND STATE PRESCHOOL FOR ALL AGE
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES REGARDLESS OF
INCOME. SECOND ALL STUDENTS
PARTICIPATING IN STATE PRESCHOOL
WILL MAINTAIN CONTINUOUS
ELIGIBILITY. FOR TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS INSTEAD OF TWELVE MONTHS
AFTER ELIGIBILITY IS CONFIRMED.
AND FINALLY PROVIDERS THAT HAVE
SERVE ALL ELIGIBLE THREE AND
FOUR YEAR OLDS IN OUR SERVICE.
WILL BE ALLOWED TO SERVE TWO
YEAR OLD CHILDREN. THAT INCLUDES
MY REMARKS AND I'M HAPPY TO
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT
NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO VIRGINIA
EARLY FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS VIRGINIA EARLY WITH THAT
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ON BEHALF OF. PUBLIC
CONSTRUCTION. SO WE REALLY WANT
THE FLAG HOW MUCH WE APPRECIATE
YOU IF WE CAN'T DO THAT SB
MINISTRATION- WE NEED TO EXCUSE
ME TO SAY WE CAN BARELY HEAR YOU
AND I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S ON OUR
SIDE TO YOUR SIDE SO OFTEN NOW I
CAN HEAR MY MIKE WAS TURNED UP
SO I THINK YOU'RE OKAY SO WANTED
TO KEEP GOING. I CAN YOU HEAR ME
NOW YES. MUCH BETTER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SO I HAD VIRGINIA
EARLYCALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS AND
THIS BUDGET AROUND BUILDING
MACHINE INVESTMENTS FROM
MULTILINGUAL LEARNERS AND
ENSURING STABILITY FOR CHILDREN
ENROLLED IN STATE. FUNDING WE
BELIEVE THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT
NEED TO IMPROVE AS MR CABRAL
MENTIONED IN HIS REMARKS I
CALIFORNIA LAGS BEHIND OTHER
STATES IN THE NOTING NATION IN
TERMS OF PROVIDING SERVICES FOR
PRESCHOOL AGE CHILDREN. WITH
DISABILITIES IN THEIR LEAST
RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT AND THIS
MEANS THAT PART THAT PROVIDING
SERVICES IN PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS
INSTEAD OF AND SPECIAL DAY
CLASSROOMS THAT. ONLY SERVE
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES. SO I
HAS ACTUALLY BEEN DECREASING ITS
INCLUSION RATE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
WE WERE SERVING 40% OF
PRESCHOOLERS IN INCLUSIVE
SETTINGS. I WHERE IS NOW AS MR
CABRAL MENTIONED IT I'VE JUST
UNDER 30% IN THE WIND. AS A
PROBE AND BEST FITS IN NEEDS
PROVIDE THOSE INCLUSIVE SETTINGS
FOR CHILDREN WITH IEPS OR
INDIVIDUAL EDUCATION PLANS
INCREASE WILL CREATES A
FOUNDATION OF SUPPORT THAT WILL
FOLLOW EACH CHILD INTO
ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY
EDUCATION. ALSO BENEFITS
CHILDREN BOTH WITH AND WITHOUT
DISABILITIES. BASED ON THE
RESEARCH IF CHILDREN WITH AYE I
EAT PEAS ARE NOT SERVICE
INCREASED WANT THIS THE STUDYING
RESEARCH HAS THAT THEY WILL HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO ACCESS GENERAL
EDUCATION AND TEND TO REMAIN AND
SPECIAL DAY CLASSES. RESEARCH
ALSO SUPPORTS THOSE BEST
PRACTICES I'VE INCREASING THE
PROPORTION OF TIME SPENT IN
GENERAL EDUCATION SETTINGS ARE
STRONG PREDICTORS OF ACADEMIC
GROWTH AND IMPROVED OUTCOMES FOR
THE MAJORITY OF CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES. SO AS WE LOOK THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL STRATEGIES THAT
THE OTHERS HAVE SUMMARIZED HIS
STRATEGIES WILL REALLY HELP US
GET TO A HIGHER INCLUSION RATE
IN OUR CALIFORNIA STATE. PROGRAM
WE SEE THAT THERE NEARLY SIX
THIRTY SIX THOUSAND PRESCHOOL
AGE CHILDREN WITH IRAQIS THAT
ARE NOT BEING SERVED IN AN
INCLUSIVE SETTINGS. SO GIVEN
THIS WE DO EXPECT THAT THE S. P.
T. OR STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS
WILL BE ABLE TO MEET THIS 10%
REQUIREMENT. ESPECIALLY IF THEY
ARE GIVEN TIME AND SUPPORT TO DO
SO AS AS IN AS IS THE CASE AND
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL.
WE THINK THE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS IN THE BUDGET BUT IT
JUST ACTORS AND WITH A FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE
INCLUSIVE EARLY EDUCATION
EXPANSION PROGRAM. AND THE EARLY
IDENTIFICATION PIECES WITH WILL
DISCUSS IN THE NEXT I DON'T
REALLY GOING TO HELP PROGRAMS
WITH MEETING THIS. 10%
REQUIREMENTS. ALSO GREAT OF.
THAT PROPOSED INVEST. TO
INCREASE THEY JUST FACT FOR
CHILDREN THAT ARE LANGUAGE
LEARNERS. AND THIS WAS THE SOME
OF THE NEWER. CONTRACTORS WILL.
AROUND HOW WORK WITH. WITH THAT
THAT THAT SPEAK MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES I PURSUANT TO THE
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN SIXTY
THREE THAT WAS SIGNED LAST YEAR
. I'M TWENTY FOUR MONTH
ELIGIBILITY WE APPRECIATE THIS
ONE SINCE WE KNOW FROM THE
RESEARCH THAT HAVING TWO YEARS
OF QUALITY EARLY LEARNING BEFORE
KINDERGARTEN IS BENEFICIAL AND
AS MR CABRAL SAID THIS WILL HELP
WITH DECREASING ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN. ENSURE EQUITY ACROSS
COUNTIES HAS TWELVE FIFTEEN
PAPER. THAT WE ALSO HEAR FROM A
THAT THIS MAY HELP WITH
PARTNERING. I WERE YOU PEAK OR
UNIVERSAL PRE K. SPENT. I SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FOR WON'T HAVE TO AS
MUCH WORK JUST CHILDREN TO YOUR
- IN TERMS OF SERVING TWO YEAR
OLD CHILDREN STATE CRISP WE KNOW
THAT UNDER THE PRINT LANGUAGE
THERE LAST PRIORITY. AND SINCE
AS MISS NUMBER MORE INSIDE A THE
LAST PANEL ONLY 13% ELIGIBLE FOR
YEAR OLD CHILDREN ARE SERVED WE
THINK THAT TODD THREE YEAR OLD
CHILDREN MAY BE ENROLLED BEFORE
TWO YEAR OLD. HOWEVER WE ALSO
NOTE THAT TWO YEAR OLD CHILDREN
ARE IN A DIFFERENT DEVELOPMENTAL
SPACE OTHERS HAVE MENTIONED THE
PIECES AROUND THE DIFFERENT
RATIOS WITH A ONE TO FOUR I
DON'T CHILD RATIO FOR TWO YEAR
OLDS. I WHERE IS WE HAVE A WIND
EIGHT ADULT CHILD RATIO WERE
ASKED RECENT WORKS SO GIVEN
THESE DIFFERENT RATIOS WE'VE
HEARD A LOT FROM STATE PRESCHOOL
CONTRACTORS. THAT THEY WOULD
LIKE TO SEE AN ADDITIONAL
ADJUSTMENT FACTOR TO SUPPORT
THAT PROCESS THAT'S THIRTY NEEDS
CHILDREN WITH HIGHER. RATIO
THANK YOU SO MUCH HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY. YOU HAVE AT THE OF.
TIME I'M ALSO PRICE PROFITER THE
DIRECTOR OF OUR DIVISION HEATHER
CAL. THE DIRECTOR SPECIAL
INTERESTS DIVISION IN ADDITION
TO THEY'RE NOT. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CALL THE IS THE APPROPRIATE
TIME FOR QUESTIONS DID NOT AM
GOING TO ASK MY CAR. FIRST
DEFEAT EITHER ONE OF THEM. HAS
QUESTIONS ON. A SENATOR MENDOZA
SENT SENATOR JOE BOB GIVE ANY
QUESTIONS. SHE DOESN'T SO. THEN
LOW ME ASK. IN OUR LET ME PLAY
AWFUL FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION- A REPRESENTATIVE JUST
SAID AND MAYBE DIRECT THIS TO
FINANCE AND WHAT THE WTO COMMENT
. ALTHOUGH THE OWNER OR THIS DID
COMMENT- ON WHY DID. PROPOSES TO
EXPAND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM ELIGIBILITY TO
TWO YEAR OLDS WHEN ONLY A SMALL
PORTION OF ELIGIBLE THREE YEAR
OLDSARE SERVED WOULDN'T IT MAKE
SENSE TO PRIORITIZE TO THREE
YEAR OLDS BEFORE WE MOVED TO THE
TWO YEAR OLDS. BUT CHAIR JERRY
BROWN BUT THE CURRENT FINANCE I
CAN TAKE A STAB AT THAT QUESTION
I WOULD NOTE THAT WE IN OUR
PRIORITIES DO YOU HAVE A FOUR
YEAR OLD PRIORITIZE BEFORE THREE
YEAR OLDS AND THROUGH YOUR ART.
THREE YEAR OLD PRIORITIZE BEFORE
FOR A TWO YEAR OLDS SO WHAT WE
DID IT EXPAND THE ELIGIBILITY TO
INCLUDE TWO YEAR OLDS. WE ARE
STILL PRIORITIZING FOUR AND
THREE YEAR OLDS BEFORE TWO YEAR
OLDS. OKAY THE DOES THE L. A-
WISH TO. COMMENT HERE. I KNOW
YOU ALREADY WAITED A LITTLE ON
THIS BUT IT'S LIKE YOU HAVE
ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO ADD. BUT
I WOULD JUST SAY I THINK AS OUR-
ZERO MENTIONED THIS IS UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL.
ACCURATE BED TWO YEAR OLDS FIRST
OF ALL I WOULD BE A CHOICE
PROVIDERS DO NOT HAVE TO SECURE
BUT IT THAT WOULD BE ANOTHER
OPTION BUT- IT WOULD BE SORT OF
THERE'S A LONG LIST OF
PRIORITIZATION. AS YOU MENTIONED
GETTING THE QUESTION WOULD
BECOME MORE BROADLY RIGHT NOW
IT'S A PRESCHOOL IF SPORTING
COME ELIGIBLE- THREE YEAR OLDS-
ONE POTENTIAL. OPTION AND I
THINK ON THE RECOMMENDATION OF
THE JUSTICE. OF THIS WATER COULD
BE TO USE A ONE TO OPEN UP THE-
FOR BURIAL MORE BROADLY SO THAT
. THEY WE INCREASE THE INCOME.
OR WE MAKE ALL YEAR OLDS
AVAILABLE BY WOULD BE ANOTHER
OPTION AS OPPOSED TO THREE THREE
TO OLDS BUT THE PROGRAM WHAT IT.
WILL BE SERVING THE SAME AGE
KIDS SO WOULD BE A LITTLE BIT
EASIER TO SERVE AS A BUSINESS
OWNER BECOMES A QUESTION OF
WHETHER- IN THE LONG RUN IT
MAKES SENSE TO SAVE. GIVE ME
ACCESS TO OF PRE VERSUS-
PROVIDING. A PROVIDING SOME YEAR
OLDS AND- OR FAMILIES MIGHT BE
INTERESTED IN PROGRAM BOB TOOK
TO HAVE A- THANK YOU AND I THINK
. THAT MAKES MY POINT WHICH IS I
HOPE OVER THE FEW MONTHS. ALL
THE GIVES INTO IN THIS WILL BE
COULD. WHEN WE COME BACK AND BE
. WE TO A LOOK FOOT. IT I THANK
. SOME OF THOSE OPTIONS TO BE ON
THE- ARE THEY LET ME ASK. WITH
REGARD TO THE- OF THE PERCENT
FOR SERVINGS WAS. NEEDS BOB JUST
TO WEEKS THE TO THIS IS FOR HOW
DO WE THE PROGRAM THE-
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL. TO
MEET THAT PERCENT REQUIRE IN
ORDER TO THAT ARE GOING TO BE IN
THE WAY OF THAT THE WE SHOULD BE
A- TO HELP THEM MEET THE 10%
WE'VE HEARD. ANECDOTALLY FROM
THE FIELD AND THAT THE BIGGEST
BARRIER TRISTER TO SERVING
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES WAS-
JUST THAT THAT COST B. THE
AMOUNT THAT THEY WERE RECEIVING
TO SERVE THESE STUDENTS WAS NOT
COVERING THE COST OF SERVING
STUDENTS WITH SIGNIFICANT NEEDS
WHICH IS WHY WE INCREASED THE
ADJUSTMENT FACTOR FROM ONE POINT
FIVE FOUR. TWO TWO POINT FOUR
WHICH IS A RATHER SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASE- YUP. WE'VE BOTH. I
TAKE OVER HERE SO CERTAINLY
CHRIS FOR EXAMPLE OF FINANCE SO
CERTAINLY- WE ALL THAT WE DO BUT
THAT THAT- THIS THE PROPOSAL WE
FORWARD IS STRUCK IN A WAY THAT
IS ATTEMPTING TO BUILD CAPACITY
ATTEMPTING TO GUARANTEED THAT
THE ENROLLMENT OF THE ABILITY TO
ENROLL STRING WITH DISABILITIES
WITHIN THAT 10% IS PRIORITIZED
AND AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS- AND-
AND AVAILABLE WHEN THOSE
STUDENTS BECOME ELIGIBLE OR NEED
THAT- THAT FOUGHT. I ANSWER YOU
KNOW WE UNDERSTAND THAT- WE HAVE
OPINION PROPOSAL TO HELP OUR
CONTRACTORS WITH DEVELOPING
INCLUSIVE ENVIRONMENTS THE EARLY
INCLUSIVE EDUCATE OUR EARLY AT
THE INCLUSIVE EARLY EXPANSION OR
EARLY EDUCATION EXPANSION
PROGRAM- R. I. D. E. E. P- I
LOVE EVERYBODY STRUGGLING
WITHOUT HAVING TO ACTUALLY
TRANSLATE. THE ACRONYM SO THANK
YOU. YES ARE WE DO AND INVEST
THAT WILL TALK ABOUT IN THE NEXT
ITEM THAT. SUPPORT FOR SOME OF
THE TYPE PASS OF DEVELOPMENT HAS
OF- YOU KNOW STUDENTS TO. AND
ENVIRONMENT SO WHAT WE THAT YOU
KNOW A LOT OF THE BARRIERS ARE
RELATED TO THE COST PROVIDING
SERVICES- BUT WE CERTAINLY
PROVIDE SUPPORT TO DO THAT IN
THE OUT YEARS TO BUILD CAPACITY
ALSO WE HAVE BUILT THE-
STRUCTURE IN A WAY. WHERE YOU A
CONTRACTOR IS NOT MEETING THE
10% MINIMUM REQUIREMENT- THAT
THEY RECEIVE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION FOR
SEVERAL YEARS BEFORE YOU
ACTUALLY WOULD GET TO A POINT
WHERE THERE WOULD BE A FISCAL
ADJUSTMENT YOUR CONTRACTS OR
GOAL. IS TO BUILD CAPACITY OUR
GOAL IS TO TRY AND HELP OUR
CONTRACTORS GET TO THE
REQUIREMENT BUT WE YOU KNOW WE
RECOGNIZE THAT IN SOME CASES
THERE MAY NEED TO BE SOME LEEWAY
IN HOW THEY GET THEIR- AND SOME
ADDITIONAL TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND HOW THEY GET THERE THAT'S
BUILT INTO THE COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH. BEFORE OKAY IT A
APPRECIATE THOSE CA. BECAUSE I
THE- THAT I JUST WANNA MAKE
EVERY AWARE TO WHAT BARRIER
MIGHT BE HOW THEY HAVE TO BE A
EVEN THOUGH. YOU'RE DOING YOUR
BEST AND WE EVEN HAVE AN ITEM IN
THE NEXT ONE THAT WE HAVEN'T
TALKED ABOUT YET SENATE ROAD
SHOW BUT DID YOU HAVE A QUESTION
OR COMMENT ON THIS. A REALLY
QUICK QUESTION- I THINK IT GOES
HERE- ARE THERE ANY CHALLENGES
WITH DIRECTING OR REDIRECTING
FUNDING TO NON. ALLEY A
PROVIDERS. YES THERE ARE THERE
IS SOME CHALLENGE DEPENDING ON
THE FUNDING SOURCE BETWEEN
DIRECTING MORE RESOURCES TO
ELEAZAR OR NON ELLIE- VERY
SPECIFICALLY OUR LED- PROVIDERS
ARE FUNDED WITH PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT RESOURCES. AND OUR
NON ELLIE A PROVIDERS ARE FUNDED
WITH GENERAL FUND RESOURCES SO
THAT THE DIFFERENT FUNDING
SOURCES DO CREATE SOME
CHALLENGES BETWEEN DIRECTING
THAT THE FUNDING THAT WE PUT
FORWARD. UP TO ONE ENTITY VERSUS
THE OTHER. GO AHEAD. JUST AS A
FIVE UP SO ARE WE DOING MITIGATE
. THOSE CHALLENGE. FROM WHAT WE
HAVE DONE OUR JOB TRYING
APPROACH AS WE DEEPER. A CHEN
FUND. IT'S ROUGHLY A HUNDRED AND
TEN POINT SIX MILLION GENERAL
FUND AS WELL AS A HUNDRED NINETY
SEVEN POINT- ARE BROADLY HUNDRED
NINETY SEVEN MILLION PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT THE ADJUSTMENT FACTOR
INCREASES RECOGNIZING. THAT BOTH
OF THE- PROVIDERS WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO SERVE THE 10% SO WE
TRY TO ACCOMMODATE. THE INCREASE
ON BULL THE NON L. THE A SIDE OF
THE PROGRAM AND THE- NON LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCY SIDE OF THE
PROGRAM AND LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES FIND OF THE PROGRAM AND
WHEN WE GET TO THE NEXT ITEM WE
ARE CERTAINLY ENCOURAGING. OUR
NON LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCY
PROVIDERS TO WORK WITH THEIR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THEIR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCY PARTNERS TO
ACCESS THE INCLUSIVE EARLY
EDUCATION EXPANSION. PROGRAM
FUNDING AS WELL. GIVEN THAT THAT
PROGRAM IS PROPOSED TO BE FUNDED
WITH PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
RESOURCE. THE SECOND PLEASE YOUR
QUESTION. MMHM THEN LET ME MAKE
ONE COMMENT BEFORE WE CONCLUDE
THIS ITEM IN THAT IS- I. REALLY
APPRECIATE AND DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THE ELIGIBILITY
ORDERED THAT IS LISTED HERE UP
IF IT MAKES SENSE WHEN YOU READ
IT BUT I JUST. I'M ALWAYS
NERVOUS WHEN YOU HAVE SIX
DIFFERENT PRIORITIES THAT WERE
VERY FINE TUNE IN ASCENDING
ORDER OF THAT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAVING TO FOLLOW THOSE
IS BOUND TO HAVE A PROBLEM
SOMEWHERE ALONG THE WAY SO UP
I'LL BE INTERESTED IF WE IN FACT
ADOPT THIS THIS YEAR. TO HAVE A
REPORT BACK ON HOW EASY IT IS
FOR THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
NAVIGATE ALL THOSE PRIORITIES
ARE NOT A SMALL NUMBER OF
STUDENTS I KNOW THEIR STUDENTS
THAT REALLY WITH THE DATA FIVE
NEEDS THAT THAT PUT THEM IN THE
CATEGORY BUT- I JUST HAVE THAT.
ARE CONCERNED WITH THAT BOM I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE PANELISTS
ON THAT APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION AND WE WILL MOVE TO
ISSUE NUMBER THREE WHICH IS
SUPPORTING PRESCHOOL AGE
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES OUR
OUR PANEL IS ONCE AGAIN MR
CABRAL FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE ONCE AGAIN MISS
LIEBERMAN FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THEN STEVEN PROFITER
FROM THE DIRECTOR FOR EARLY
EDUCATION- AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WILL GO IN THAT ORDER
WELCOME BACK MR. CABRAL
DEMOCRATS. LEGISLATIVE OFFICE.
BUT- THIS ITEM- NUMBER PROPOSED
LETTERS TO. THIS SUPPORT FOR-
APRIL PROVIDERS OUT OF ATTEMPTED
. SERVE ADDITIONAL OF THE- HELLO
OF WHICH OF THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE-
INCLUSIVE EARLY EDUCATION
EXPANSION PROGRAM. BOB THIS IS A
PROGRAM WHERE- IT SPECIFICALLY
BECAUSE- AS MISTER FERGUSON
MENTIONED EARLIER THIS IS
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING. ONLY THE SCHOOL BASED
PROVIDERS- SCHOOL DISTRICT KIND
OF THAT IS BECAUSE YOU CAN APPLY
FOR THESE FUNDS THE BACON. APPLY
FOR BUT AND THEY CAN USE THIS
FOR TO- DO ADDITIONAL TRAINING-
THE FACILITY UPGRADES OR TO
PURCHASE A- TO MAKE THEIR-
PROGRAMS MORE INCLUSIVE. OF ALL
THE FIVE MILLION FIFTY MILLION
IS FOR STATEWIDE TRAINING. AND
THAT'S THE WAY TRAINING AS
ASSEMBLY THE FUNDING WOULD GO
TO- AND I WE LOCAL EDUCATION IT
AGENCIES SO. RIGHT I GRANT
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION BY
TURNING. R. SEVEN A LETTER THAT
TRAINING YOUR HAVE- SEE A
COMMUNITY BASE OR- BENEFIT FROM
THAT TRAINING THE JUST CAN'T GET
THE DIRECTLY TO. DO THE TRAINING
UPGRADE INSULTS. ON THERE IS AN
ADDITIONAL. TWO MILLION DOLLARS
THAT THE SO WITH- IMPROVING
EARLY I DON'T SO MILLION IS FOR
THE PART OF EDUCATION TO DEVELOP
A TOOLS FOR OUR- CHILDREN RISK
FOR DRUG DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS
ARE RUNNING. AND IN SIXTEEN OF-
POSSIBLY PROVIDED- TRAINING AND
SUPPORT THE PROVIDERS. I THINK
THIS IS WHAT AREAS WE DID THAT-
AS WOMEN EARLIER THAT BAD THE
GUY. WAS WORTH PER. WE DO HAVE
COME WITH ENSURING THAT THERE A
MISSED IS SUFFICIENT SUPPORT FOR
PROVIDERS AND PREDICT FOR THOSE
OUR COMMUNITY BASED ON. THA NON
INSTEAD OF NOT ONLY ALL NOT
MONTHS PROVIDER BUT OUR
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS- SO
WOMEN'S A BIGGER MORE BROAD- IN
THE STATE PRESCHOOL. 4% CHILDREN
- ENROLLED IN THE PRESCHOOL
UNTIL JUST. IF YOU DON'T AT THAT
BY THE TYPE OF. IT'S THERE ISN'T
A SIGNIFICANT OF. THE FOR THE
SCHOOL BAY FORTY POINT PERCENT
OF THEIR CHIU- IT'S A PRESCHOOL
ARGYL DISABILITY FOR COMMUNITIES
OF THIS IS THAT THE ONLY TWO
NINE PER. THEY HAVE A LOWER.
ENROLLMENT OR- I'M ALSO. SCHOOL
BASED PROGRAMS ARE GOING TO HAVE
A LOT MORE TO PASS. ON IT PART
BECAUSE OUR SCHOOL THIS HAVE A
SPECIAL EDUCATION TO THEY ARE
RESPOND FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
SERVICES. FOR THE ARE THREE AND
FOUR YEAR SO BUT FIND IT EASIER
THAN ARBOR STUDENTS TO THE
PRIEST PROGRAM INITIAL
DISCORDANT. BETWEEN OF IT'S GOOD
EXPERT AND WITH A STATE
PRESCRIBER. COUNTY OPPOSITE
SIMILARLY THE SPECIAL. EXPO ON
ADVOCATE HELP WITH. IMPLEMENTING
THE ISSUES. PRODUCT MAYBE SORT
OF IN THE HAVE THIS OF COMPOUND
. ONE OF THE MY BE OPERATE STATE
CHRIS PROGRAMS SUPPORT SORRY
HAVE START FROM WHICH HAVE. A
REQUIREMENT TO SERVE OUR MORE
JUNIOR DISABILITY BUT MANY THEM
DO NOT. UNTIL THEY MAY NOT HAVE
THAT SAME- ACCESS TO SPECIAL
EDUCATION EXPERTS. FOR THE STATE
LEVEL SYSTEMS THAT- BUT THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
CAN ALSO ACCESS- THERE ALSO MAY
BE OTHER WAYS THAT THE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
FINDING OTHER SOURCES OF
FUNDING. FOR EXAMPLE RIGHT NOW
THERE IS A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION AND FEDERAL FOR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT FUNDS THAT ARE.
ADMINISTERED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES NOW WITH THE
TRANSITION OF. HEALTH CARE TO
DISCUSS. BY FUNDING IS DEPICTED
STARTED WRITING ACTIVITIES BUT
SOME OF THAT FUNDING COULD
POTENTIALLY BE REDIRECTED TO BE.
USED TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT- SIMILAR THE WITH THE
LETTER MARIJUANA THAT GREATER
FOR OF THAT SIXTY. THAT'S I DO.
OF THIRTY SOMETHING AMOUNT OF
FIVE OR SOME OF. SIR THAT. A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
HAVE ACT TO. AS WITH. THE BURDEN
THE OF ABOUT I WOULD MOST
BENEFIT FROM THE SUPPORT. BUT MY
REMARKS BEEN OBSERVED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
HELLO AGAIN JODY WE OF THE FIND
I'LL BE COMING FOR. TO EXPAND
THAT DIDN'T EARLY AND EXPANSION
PROGRAM AND THE PROPOSAL FOR
EDUCATOR TRAINING ON PRESCHOOL
ASSESSMENT TOOLS. AS YOU MAY
RECALL THE INCLUSIVE EARLY
EDUCATION EXPANSION PROGRAM WAS
PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
AS A PART OF THE EDUCATION
OMNIBUS BILL. AND THE PROGRAM IS
A COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM FOR
ALLOCATION TO LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
INCLUSIVE EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE PROGRAMS FOR CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES. FUNDS MAY BE USED
FOR FACILITIES ADOPTING A QUICK
MAN AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. THE ADMINISTRATION
RECOGNIZES THAT INCLUSIVE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS ARE
BENEFICIAL TO THESOCIAL
EMOTIONAL AND ACADEMIC
DEVELOPMENT OF NOT ONLY STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES BUT ALSO
GENERAL EDUCATION STUDENTS. THE
BUDGET INCLUDES FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION ONE TIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT THE INCLUSIVE EARLY
EDUCATION EXPANSION PROGRAM
SUPPORT GENERAL EDUCATION AND
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS IN
INCLUSVE CLASSROOMS. OF THESE
FUNDS THE SUPERINTENDENT
ALLOCATE UP TO FIFTY MILLION TO
WORK WITH A LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES SUCH AS THE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION TO PROVIDE
STATEWIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND SUPPORT EFFORTS TO OFFER. A
LINE EARLY EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
THE SECOND REVERSAL IS AIMED AT
IDENTIFYING CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES EARLY AND STARTING
INTERVENTIONS A YOUNG AGE AS
PRESCHOOL AND TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN OR EXPANDED WE
SHOULD FOR THE REFINED
DIAGNOSTIC THE DIAGNOSTIC
ASSESSMENT TOOLS USED FOR EARLY
IDENTIFICATION OF STUDENTS WITH
LEARNING DISABILITIES. AND
ENSURE THAT TEACHERS RECEIVE THE
TRAINING TO OFFICIALLY USE THOSE
TOOLS AND- I KNOW WHAT THIS THE
BUDGET INCLUDES TWO MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND TO INCORPORATE
EARLY IDENTIFICATION FOR
LEARNING DISABILITIES. INTO THE
DESIRED RESULTS DEVELOPMENTAL
PROFILE INCLUDING A PROCESS FOR
FOLLOW UP BY EXTRA VALUE WAITERS
AND SIXTY MILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND TO PROVIDE TRAINING FOR THE
EDUCATORS ON EFFECTIVE USE OF
THESE TOOLS. THAT CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW
WILL. MOVE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN BURSTS EVEN BROADER
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TWENTY FOUR. CT
APPRECIATES THE PROPOSED FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FUNDS
TO SUPPORT THE INCLUSIVE EARLY
EDUCATION EXPANSION PROGRAM.
WHICH FUNDS INFRASTRUCTURE
NECESSARY TO SUPPORT SERVING
BOTH CHILDREN IN GENERAL
EDUCATION AND SPECIAL EDUCATION
IN INCLUSIVE CLASSROOMS. WE KNOW
THIS INVESTMENT IS MUCH NEEDED
ESPECIALLY WITH THE NEW
REQUIREMENTS 410% OF CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
CONTRACTORS. FUNDED ENROLLMENT.
TO BE CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES. DURING THE INITIAL
REQUEST FOR APPLICATIONS FOR
THIS PROGRAM THE C. E. RECEIVED
REQUESTS IN EXCESS OF THREE
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLARS.
FAR EXCEEDING THE ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY SIX BILLION IN FUNDING
THAT WAS AVAILABLE FOR THAT
ALLOCATION. ANECDOTALLY OTHER
ELEAZAR INTERESTED IN APPLYING
BUT DID NOT FOR VARIOUS REASONS.
TO SENATOR OF TROUBLES ON THE
PREVIOUS ISSUE AND MR BERLE'S
COMMENTS EARLIER WE ALSO KNOW
THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE STATE
PRESCHOOL HAVE SHARED WITH US
THAT THEY WOULD GREATLY BENEFIT
FROM SUPPORT PROVIDED THROUGH
THIS PROGRAM. SO WE WILL ALIGN
WITH THE L. A- IN. ASKING FOR
FUNDS TO MEET THEIR NEEDS. HOW
WE THERE WILL BE HIGH DEMAND FOR
LED. FOR THE FIVE AND FIVE
MILLION SO WE WOULD REQUEST THAT
ADDITIONAL FUNDS BE APPROPRIATED
TO MEET THE STATE. WE ARE HAPPY
TO WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE LEGISLATURE ON WHAT
FUNDING FOR ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS. WHICH WOULD MEET
THE NEED HERE. ONE LESSON THAT
CD LEARN FROM THE INITIAL ROUND
OF THIS GRANT WAS THE NEED FOR
STATE AND REGIONAL LEVEL SYSTEMS
SYSTEMS BUILDING. AND SUPPORT
FOR THE INCLUSIVE EARLY
EDUCATION EXPANSION PROGRAM
FUNDS- SO THEY ARE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE- AS A RESULT WE ARE WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE FIFTY
MILLION SET ASIDE TO ADDRESS
STATE LEVEL SYSTEMS BUILDING. IN
A LINE LOCAL PRACTICE WITH THE
RESEARCH AND PRACTICE BASED
STRATEGIES THAT BEST PROMOTE.
STUDENT OUTCOMES AND PROGRAM
QUALITY. IN ORDER TO HELP THESE
PROGRAMS RUN SMOOTHLY THERE
NEEDS TO BE PROPER PREPARATION
AND SYSTEMS PUT IN PLACE TO
SUPPORT THEM. THE CITY HAS TAKEN
NOTED THESE AND RESOURCES
PROVIDED WILL ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS ARE SUPPORTED BY
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
PRACTICE BASED COACHING IN JOB
EMBEDDED PROFESSIONAL SUPPORT-
TO FOR GRANTEES AS NECESSARY
AROUND INCLUSION SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL WELL BEING OF
CHILDREN. AND STRATEGIES TO
LEVERAGE ALL AVAILABLE FUNDING
FOR INCLUSIVE. ENVIRONMENTS IN
EARLY EDUCATION. THIS E. O.
APPRECIATES INVEST FOR EARLY
IDENTIFICATION OF LEARNING
DISABILITIES. EARLY DETECTION IS
A PRO. ACTIONS AND NOT A WAIT TO
FAIL MODEL EARLY IDENTIFICATION
PROCESS OFTENTIMES CAN PREVENT A
REFERRAL SPECIALIST OCCASION BY
INTENSELY ADDRESSING NEEDS AT
EARLY AGE RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
STUDENTS ARE NOT IDENTIFIED
EARLY IN SCHOOL AGE YEARS
OFTENTIMES ARE REFERRED TO
SPECIAL EDUCATION IN LATER
GRADES AFTER A SIZEABLE GAP AND
EXPECTED OUTCOMES AND
PERFORMANCE HAS SURFACED. EARLY
INTERVENTION IS MORE EFFECTIVE
IN TERMS OF COST AND HEALTH THEN
LATER MEDIATION FOR EXAMPLE
PARTICIPATION IN HIGH QUALITY
PRE K. THESE TWO SYSTEM
STATISTICALLY SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTIONS TO SPECIAL EDUCATION
THIS. WELL CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY
IMPLEMENTS THE CALIBRATION TOOL
FOR DESIRED RESULTS DEVELOPMENT
PROFILE WE DO NOT INCLUDE USE
THAT EARLY IDENTIFICATION
IDENTIFICATION TOOL IN OUR STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS THE VOTE
ALWAYS HAVE THAT ON OUR WISH
LIST. INCLUDING IT WOULD ALIGN
STATE PRESCHOOL AND HEAD START
AND WITH OUR QUALITY COUNTS
CALIFORNIA OR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT SYSTEM. THERE ARE
MULTIPLE TYPES OF LEARNING
DISABILITIES THAT EXIST THAT CAN
VARY SIGNIFICANTLY AND HOW THEY
AFFECT THE CHILD'S ABILITY TO
LEARN. ALIGNMENT WITH THE
RESEARCH AND USING THESE
RESOURCES THE CITY WOULD ENGAGE
EXPERTS IN THE FIELD TO REVIEW
CURRENT TOOLS AND DEVELOPING
EARLY IDENTIFICATION CHECKLIST
TO WORK TO ASSIST IN IDENTIFYING
LEARNING DISABILITIES. TO
REMEDIATE AND EARLY EDUCATION
AND FOR MEDIATION IS NOT
IMPROVING THE CHILD'S ABILITY
CONSIDERATION TO REFER TO
SPECIAL EDUCATION FOR AN
EVALUATION. AS PART OF OUR WORK
ON THIS WE WOULD BE PARTICULARLY
INTERESTED IN A TOOL THAT IS LOW
TO NO COST. WE ALSO GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE RECOGNITION IN
THE BUDGET THE CREATING THE
TOOLS NOT ENOUGH THAT RESOURCES
ARE NEEDED TO TRAIN AND PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. AND
TRAINING AROUND IMPLEMENTING THE
TOOL AND USING THE INFORMATION
FOR REFERRALS INFORMATION TO
FAMILIES AND BEST SUPPORTING
INDIVIDUAL CHILDREN'S NEEDS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY AND I HAVE
CERTAINLY WORKING FOR JUNIOR
EARLY AND HEATHER CALORIES WITH
ME TODAY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
WE'RE NOT GOING TO MOVE TO
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE AND
LET ME ASK MY COLLEAGUES IF THEY
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON THE SIDE.
R. I DON'T HAVE QUESTIONS FROM
COLLEAGUES SO LET ME ASK ONE
MYSELF. IN. HE'S MAKES I THINK
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS THE
BEST PLACE TO START BUT I WAS
WONDERING TO SPECIAL EDUCATION
LOCAL PLAN AREAS OR SELF OF THE
SYSTEMS- OF WHAT IF ANY ORDER
THOUGH THEIR ROLES- IN THIS OF
JUST BECAUSE- WE CONSIDERED THEM
AND CERTAIN ISSUES IN A PREVIOUS
HEARING I JUST LIKE TO KNOW HOW
THEY FIT IN THIS RECOMMENDATION
AND MAYBE START WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THIS IS
CHRIS FERGUSON WILL DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE SO I THINK YOU KNOW
IN REGARDS TO SPECIAL EDUCATION
WE THINK THAT THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION RESOURCE. ARE LEADS TO
NOT HAVE AN ACTIVE ARE DEFINED
ROLE IN IN PROVIDING SUPPORT TO
PRESCHOOL LEVEL NOR ARE THEY
INTENDED TO HAVE A ROLE IN THIS
PARTICULAR AREA OF WORK HOWEVER-
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACTED TO INCLUDE FIFTEEN MILLION
ONE TIME PROP NINETY EIGHT. IN
SUPPORT OF THESE THAT SUPPORTING
INCLUSIVE PRACTICES PROJECT
WHICH IS AIMED AT INCREASING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PUPILS WITH
DISABILITIES INCLUDING PUPILS IN
PRE KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS. TO
MEANING FOR ME A PARTICIPATE IN
THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT AND INCREASE
INCLUSIVE A. R. INCLUSION OF
CHILDREN AND PUPILS WITH
DISABILITIES OF GENERAL
EDUCATION SETTINGS. THESE GOALS
ARE I CONTINUE TO BE AREAS OF
FOCUS AS WE LOOK TO ENHANCE THE
STATE'S PRESCHOOL ASSESSMENT
TOOLS AS A WAY TO PROMOTE
STUDENT OUTCOMES AND STRENGTHEN
NOT. PROGRAM QUALITY. THANK YOU
DOES THE- LEGISLATIVE OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAVE
COMMENT EITHER ONE BEFORE WE
MOVE ON. THEY'RE BOTH CHECK FOR
THOSE OF YOU AT HOME THEY BOTH
SHOOK THEIR HEADS. UP SO- I
THINK THAT COMPLETES OUR
QUESTIONS BUT I WOULD MAKE MONEY
ONE COMMENT BECAUSE I KNOW THE
REPRESENTATIVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. MADE A POINT OF
REQUEST FOR MORE MONEY AND WE
HAVE SO MUCH THAT'S ON THE TABLE
HERE THAT WE WERE DISCUSSING
THAT JUST IT WOULD COMPETE WITH
EVERYTHING ELSE SO FAR. WITH
THAT. THAT COMPLETES OUR HEARING
OF THE THREE ISSUES AND WE START
PUBLIC COMMENT BUT BEFORE WE
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT. I
BELIEVE SENATOR MEN WANTED TO
MAKE A STATEMENT. YEAH I JUST
WANT TO SAY- AS WE GO THROUGH
SOME OF THESE DIFFERENT. K.
THROUGH TWELVE AND PRE K. T. K.
PRESCHOOL PRIORITIES. I WANNA
MAKE SURE WE DON'T LOSE THE
FOREST FOR THE TREES- I SUPPORT
A LOT OF THE PROGRAMS THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAD A GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
HAS A PROPOSED- AT THE SAME TIME
I THINK WE KNOW WHAT A HIGH
LEVEL- THAT OUR SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA BASIC INSTRUCTION CAN
BE IMPROVED THERE'S A LOT OF
ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT THERE- AND
WE ALSO KNOW THAT. THE TWO
FACTORS THAT ARE MOST IMPORTANT
IN EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES OUR
CLASSROOMS SIZE AND TEACHER
QUALITY- AND I WILL SAY THAT I
AM SOMEWHAT DISAPPOINTED TO SEE
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
REALART HAS NOT ADDRESS THIS
MORE HEAD ON. I AND IN A TIME
WHEN WE DO HAVE BOUNTIFUL
RESOURCES I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO ADDRESS ISSUES LIKE EQUITY
ANTI K. AND ANYTHING THE
GOVERNMENT A GOVERNOR IS
ADDRESSING- BUT WE DO NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR SCHOOLS ARE
SHORT UP AND NOW IS THE TIME WE
REALLY SHOULD BE PRIORITIZING
THAT. SO I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
MORE EMPHASIS PUT JUST ON
INCREASING THE SHARE OF DIVINITY
LCF AFTER SCHOOL SO THAT WE CAN
GET TO THE HARD WORK OF REDUCING
CLASS SIZES IMPROVING TEACHER
QUALITY I JUST MAKING SURE WE
HAVE GOOD TEACHER RETENTION- AND
SO I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE US EMPHASIZE
GOING FORWARD. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I THINK IT SPEAKS
TO THE COMMON I JUST MADE ABOUT
EVERYTHING THAT. COMPETES IN
THIS. IN SO. WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
PAY. COMMENT I ASK IF THERE'S
ANYBODY HERE. LET ME ASK IT
BECAUSE WE HAVE ABOUT FIFTEEN
MINUTES LET ME ASK THE
MODERATOR. THE FIRST TO WELCOME
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE AND ASK YOU
HOW MANY PEOPLE YOU MIGHT HAVE
QUEUED UP THAT MIGHT BE
INTERESTED IN MAKING A PUBLIC
COMMENT. BOB RIGHT NOW WE
ALREADY HAVE FOUR PEOPLE QUEUED
UP BEFORE EVEN GIVEN
INSTRUCTIONS WE HAVE A TOTAL OF
A THIRTEN PARTICIPANTS. THAT'S
PERFECT THEN BOB CARDEN I'M
GOING TO ALLOW ONE MINUTE FOR
EVERYBODY AND- IF WE HAVE MORE
PEOPLE QUEUE UP WE WILL JUST CUT
OFF IN ABOUT FIFTEEN MINUTES BUT
I APPRECIATE THAT BEFORE I GO
BACK TO MODERATOR. WELL LET ME
ASK IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT
IN THE HEARING ROOM IF THERE IS
PLEASE COME FORWARD. AND AND
STATE YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
AND YOU'RE LIMITED TO A
COMMITTEE TO AMEND IT BUT
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU SO MUCH MY NAME IS KIND OF
LIKE WHAT THE CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER. EVERYONE IN OUR
COMMUNITY SHOULD BE ABLE TO WORK
LIVE AND RAISE THEIR FAMILIES
WITH DIGNITY. WE SUPPORT A PRE
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAM FOR THREE
AND FOUR YEAR OLD THAT IS TRULY
UNIVERSAL WHERE NO COST EARLY
EDUCATION IS OFFERED IN A
SETTING OF A PARENT'S CHOICE.
THIS IS WHY WE ALSO URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO ADOPT THE BUDGET
THAT INCLUDES INCREASING CS PP
AND CHILD CARE SUBSIDY RATE.
WAITING FAMILY FEES IS THE
TIMBRE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR THE PARENTS CAN AFFORD TO
PARTICIPATE IN A PUBLICLY FUNDED
HEALTH CARE PROGRAM INCREASING
THE NUMBER OF VOUCHERS. AND
PAYING THE S. P. P. S. OTHER
PROVIDERS BASED ON A- VERIFIED
NEED RATHER THAN ATTENDED. THESE
POLLS ARE ENTERED. AND ADOPTING
THEM WILL BEGIN TO RECTIFY SOME
OF THE HARM FROM POLICIES THAT
EXPECT WOMEN OF COLOR THE HOLD
UP A SYSTEM WITH LITTLE TO NO
PAY DEPENDS ON MOTHERS WHO ARE
POOR TO SUBSIDIZE OTHER MOTHERS
WHO ARE POOR. AND SEVERELY
LIMITS THEIR CHOICE TO WHETHER
TO WHERE TO SEND THEIR CHILDREN
WHILE THEY WORK. THESE BUDGET
PRIORITIES ARE I'VE EXCUSE ME
I'VE LET YOU GO A BIT OVER BUT-
ABOUT I'M GOING TO GIVE
EVERYBODY A CHANCE TO SUBMIT
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS TO THE
COMMITTEE AND WE REALLY PUSH.
I'VE SEEN YOU SITTING HERE SO I
KNOW I'VE BEEN WAITING SO JUST
LET ME THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND- IF YOU HAVE
ADDITIONAL THANKS PLEASE SUBMIT.
YOU SOMEONE IS THERE ANYBODY
ELSE IN THE HEARING. ROOM THAT
WISH TO ADDRESS. SEEING NOT.
ARMADA WELL GO THE PHONE I'LL BE
LIMITING IT TO A MINUTE- OVER TO
YOU. WELCOME TO THE HEARING.
THANK YOU MUCH LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO- MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT TODAY PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO IN
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR QUICKLY
GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE IN
PLACE RIGHT BACK IN THE QUEUE.
R. EIGHT POINT ONE ZERO SO TO
OFFER PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BEGIN
TODAY MISTER CHAIR WITH MY
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIRTEEN YOUR ONLY. GOOD MORNING
SHERRY BECAUSE IF THAT I NEED
NOTHING I WOULD TELL NOW- WANTED
TO SAY THAT WE APPLAUDED OF THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSALS AND
COMMITMENT TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESCHOOL AND THE
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN- BUT
CONCURRENTLY WE ARE REALLY
CONCERNED THAT THE EXPANSION OF
BOTH PROGRAM IS AND WILL BE
UNEVEN AND INEQUITABLE. RESEARCH
SHOWS INVESTING EARLIER AT
INVESTING IN QUALITY YOU'RE THE
HIGHEST RETURN WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT WITH THIS
BUDGET FOR CHILDREN TO BENEFIT
FROM THE BEST EDUCATIONAL START
IN LIFE THAT'S WHAT'S NEEDED WE
NEED MORE ROBUST INVESTMENTS IN
COMPREHENSIVE SUPPORT FOR OUR
YOUNGEST KIDS ACROSS EARLY
CHILDHOOD. AGE ABOUT AGE
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE CARE
FOR A THREE TO FIVE YEAR OLDS
EXPANSION OF UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL
AND TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
HOW TO BE DONE PROPERLY AND THEN
HAND THEM WITH INVESTMENT IN OUR
STATE SUPPORTED EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION SYSTEM OUTSIDE THE
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM EXPANDING
ACCESS TO HIGHER PAYING JOBS IN
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM WITHOUT
PARALLEL INVESTMENT IN OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO PUT OUR DIRECTORIES
CARE AT WITH. LIFE BY CUTTING
OFF COUNTY PROVIDERS WHO WOULD
RATIONALLY BE SEEKING WORK IN
HIGHER PAYING JOBS IN THE
PRESCHOOL TK'S SYSTEM THIS IS A
WELL RESEARCHED DYNAMIC IS
HEREBY GIVES ME I'VE LET YOU GO
AWAYS OVER AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND IF YOU
HAVE ADDITIONAL OUR COMMENTS
PLEASE SUBMIT THEM TO THE
COMMITTEE. MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
THANK YOU ALLY TWENTY. TWENTY
THREE AND- CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE CONTINUE.
AT SORRY I'M THINKING REPORT THE
EXPANSION AND P. K. FOR ALL FOUR
YEAR OLDS IN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS
WE CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THAT SHE
K. CANNOT BE EXPANDED WITHIN
EXISTING RESOURCES I APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDING.
A REDUCTION OF THE PROP NINETY
GUARANTEED TO ACCOMMODATE THE
NEW GRADE LEVEL WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
TODAY ABOUT MY THE
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES AND
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE
THE RESOURCES AND SUPPORT BURKE
WILL. DEFINITELY IMPLEMENT
UNIVERSAL PKC YEAH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. MY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE FUNDING
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION ON MONDAY
SHE TO SUPPORT THE CREATION OF
PRESCHOOL AGE ABILITY FOR
PRESCHOOLERS WITH DISABILITIES
INCREASE RATE FOR ALL
RESPONSIBILITIES AND RESERVING
10% OF PRESCHOOL SPOTS FOR THESE
YOUNG LEARNERS. ALSO SUPPORT
PRESCHOOLERS WITH DISABILITIES
AFTER THAT 10% STILL HOWEVER WE
CAN MAKE THE PRIORITY LEVELS
REFORM SHE DISABILITIES TO BE
REGARDLESS. OF INCOME LEVEL.
THREE WE SUPPORT EACH FONG TO
INCREASE INCLUDED SETTINGS FROM
IS MISSING. GROUP THE ALLEY OF
THE- THAT MOM FOR MY NOT.
DISABILITY MAKE THAT MORE FROM
CHILD IN THE STATE YOUR COMPUTER
. FOR PRIORITY THIS GRANT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMON. A MODERATOR NECK CALL.
BY NINETEEN YOU ARE A- THANK YOU
MY NAME SERENA WENT AWAY FOR AND
WHICH JUST I NON CAN YOU BASED
LEN AND WE HAVE TWENTY SITES I'M
NOT SO MICHAEL ON THE L. BY THE
END FOR THINGS THAT WOULD BY
FINANCIAL BLOW A HER COLUMN.
EVERYTHING NOTED ONE ANSWER
BUILD COMBINING ONE TO WORK MORE
CLOSELY. WITH COMMUNITY BEING
FROM. THE L. MIX CELEBRITY DOWN
- CPR CARD AT ANOTHER ACT
GENERAL TRY CARE P. P. A. P. ON
PAYMENT PROGRAM. GRAND BEING
ALTERED A DIFFERENT FUNDING FOR
REIMBURSEMENT RATE AND REGIONAL
RATE MEANS HAVE. THE AMOUNT HE
DID HE CAME TWELVE PROVIDERS
TEACHERS ARE OFF EARNING WAGES
HAVE SHE TEACHER. GOING TO SERVE
OUR YOUNGEST AND MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION. NO HAPPENED HAS
DEMONSTRATED THAT HIGH QUALITY
EARLY EDUCATION BURKE THIRD
GRADE THAT COUNTS. YEAH I HATE
TO. I HATE INTERRUPT BUT YOU
KNOW COME OVER APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS YOU CAN ADD UP TO THE
COMMITTEE MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
WHY EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS PANEL AGAINST
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION ON
ISSUE TO. MINISTRATION AND
LEGISLATURE SUPPORT FOR
CALIFORNIANS MAKE THE RIVER ROAD
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION SYSTEM
AND INCLUSIVE EARLY EDUCATION
PROGRAMS IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
PROVIDING THAT OTHERWISE
ELIGIBLE FAMILIES MAY CONTINUE
TO ACCESS FEDERAL HEAD START
PROGRAM. AND STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS THE REQUESTED SUPPORT
TO BOTTOM AGE ELIGIBILITY WHICH
WOULD ALLOW FOR. AT EIGHTEEN
MONTHS OLD TWO FIVE YEAR OLD
CALIFORNIA STATE PLEASE CALL THE
S. P. T. WE APPRECIATE THE L. A-
COMMENTS ON THIS POINT RELATED
THE GENERAL CHILD CARE AND
FORWARD TO CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE COMMITTEE AND LA ON THIS
ISSUE. WITH THIS CHANGE PART
DATE THE FTP COULD THEN BE
PARTNERED WITH EARLY HEAD START
HEAD START PROGRAM. AND PROVIDES
FULL DAY COMPREHENSIVE SERVICES
TO CHILDREN AND FAMILIES LASTLY
WE ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THIS
LETTER YOU SHOULD HAVE ALREADY
RECEIVED BUT HEAD START
CALIFORNIA ON THE BUDGET REQUEST
FOR FIFTEEN FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. ON TO SUPPORT TEACHERS
SALARIES FOR HEAD START PROGRAMS
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. BY
SIXTEEN YOU ARE OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME BUT ON THE
MARTINEZ WITH RADIATION A
NETWORK OF BUSINESS LEADERS AND
SUPPORT ALL TO THE ABILITY OF
STUDENTS AND THE ECONOMY REPORTS
OF SUPPORT FOR THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION COALITION'S
BUDGET PRIORITIES. KOPET THREW
LEARNING HAS BEEN GREATLY
DISRUPTED AND ARE YOU COULD
DEMONSTRATED A SHARP DECLINE IN
THE PAPER I HELP YOU REFER
STUDENTS TO THRIVE WE NEED
ROBUST INVESTMENTS IN THE EARLY
DEVELOPMENT DESTRUCTION STUDENT
LEARNING WAS ALSO IMPACTED OUR
ECONOMIC RECOVERY THE SHORTAGE
OF QUALIFIED HEALTH CARE WORKERS
AND RISING COSTS OF RESULTS IN
THE ABSENTEEISM OF WORKING
PARENTS ESPECIALLY MOMS. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE REGULATION COMMISSION
TO SURVEY OF SENIOR BUSINESS
LEADERS TO WORK FOR COMPANIES
WITH AT LEAST FIVE MILLION AND I
DON'T THINK YOU'LL REVENUE 36%
OF EMPLOYERS REPORTED THAT WOMEN
WERE LEAVING THE WORK IN
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBERS 38% UP
TO PARTY WORKERS TALKING CHILD
CARE OF THE ISSUE THE BETTER
ARCHER. WITH 60% OF EMPLOYERS
GOVERNMENT SUPPORTED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO DEVELOP HEALTHCARE
PLANS WOULD BE INCREDIBLY
BENEFICIAL RETAINING THE WORK
FORCE WE BELIEVE THAT IT SHOULD
BE AND ECONOMIC FUTURE THAT
WORKS FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS BUT
YOU ALL COULD PORTANTINO
CRITICAL INVESTMENTS IN OUR
YOUNGER STUDENTS THANK YOU FOR
TALKING THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. WE'LL GO
TO LINE TWENTY SEVEN YOU ARE ALL
. THANK YOU CAN SENATE LAYER TO
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE HER ON OF
AS FORMULA EARLIER. THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED SEEKING. TO ENSURE
SUCCESSFUL EMPLOYMENT. OF
UNIVERSAL TRANSITION CAN BY THE
FIVE SIX SCHOOL YEAR WE ARE
APPRECIATE GOVERNOR'S. OF THE
NEED TO BETTER SUPPORT YOUR
LANGUAGE LEARNERS STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM ALONG WITH THE
TWENTY FOUR MONTH ELIGIBILITY
PROPOSAL FINALLY WE SUPPORT THE
ECT COALITION BUDGET PRIORITIES
THAT ARE NEEDED TO STABILIZE
RESTORE AND EXPAND CALIFORNIA'S
CHILD CARE SYSTEM. AND CURSED
THE LEGISLATURE TO FURTHER
SUPPORT OF THE CHILD CARE
WORKFORCE I RESTORING THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT GRANTS THAT WERE
SWEPT AT THE EARLY STAGE OF THE
PANDEMIC IN ANTICIPATION OF A
FIFTY FOUR BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
DEFICIT. THAT NEVER MATERIALIZED
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS IN PRESCHOOL
TEACHERS NEED THE FUNDS TO
REINFORCE AND EXPAND THEIR
CAPACITY TO **** CHILDREN THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. WE ALONG
FIFTY YOUR- GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN SENATOR WERE THERE
ACROSS ELLIOTT CALLING ON OF THE
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION AND
FORCE THEM IN ASSOCIATION OF
MULTISTATE MULTI SITE CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS- JUST WANNA SPEAK
BRIEFLY ON ITEM NUMBER ONE- AND-
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
WELL OFFENDER LEYVA ON. HOW TO
CREATE OPTIONS FOR FAMILIES- AND
FOR PARENTS TO CHOOSE- OPTIONS
FOR THEIR FOUR YEAR OLD THAT
WORK FOR THEIR FAMILY AND THEIR
WORK SCHEDULES- AND WITH THAT
BEING SAID I JUST WANT TO-
ALIGNED TO MY COMMENTS WITH WHAT
YOU HEARD FROM CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER- IN CHILDREN NOW ABOUT
THE IMPACT OF P. K. ON. THE
CHILD CARE FIELD AND WITH THAT I
JUST WANT TO STATE THAT- YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE IS
THE NEXT DELIVERY SYSTEM WHICH
HAS BEEN STATED NUMEROUS TIMES
BUT ALSO THAT UNIVERSAL- DOES
NOT NECESSARILY MEAN UNIFORM AND
SO WE REALLY NEED TO OYSTERS FOR
PARENTS AND FAMILIES FOR WHAT
WOULD WORK BEST FOR THEM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A MODERATOR. HOW MANY MORE PEOPLE DO WE
HAVE IN THE QUEUE. YES OUR
REMAINING WE WANT THOSE. AND
THAT'S- SO WE REALLY PER. IT
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. WE WILL I
TWENTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS ON I AM
COMMUNITIES DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS AT HEAD
START CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING TO
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT
FIFTY MILLION IN THE STATE
BUDGET TO SUPPORT HEAD START
TEACHER SALARIES. AND START
PROGRAMS ARE NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED FOR THEIR HIGH
QUALITY FOR CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES
TO DEDICATE 10% OF FACES AND
STATE PRESCHOOL CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES AND WHO PROVED
SERVICES FOOTBALL LANGUAGE PART.
YOU CAN PREVENT A BASED ON
EXISTING HEAD START STANDARDS.
BUT HAD THIRD TEACHERS ARE
STRUGGLING THE AVERAGE CONCERT
FEATURING CALIFORNIA MAKES FORTY
ONE THOUSAND A YEAR WHICH IS
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
LESS THAN THE AVERAGE
KINDERGARTEN TEACHER AND FUNDING
ALLOCATED TO INCREASE SALARIES
AND THE FACT THAT I PROGRAMS DID
NOT IMPROVE COMPENSATION FOR
FEDERALLY FUNDED HEAD START
TEACHERS. WE AFTER THE COMMITTEE
RECOGNIZED COULD START AS A
VITAL PART OF THE MIX OF THE
FREE SYSTEM AND REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT AND THAT OUR PROGRAM CAN
CONTINUED RECRUITING AND
RETAINING OUR HIGH QUALITY
TEACHERS. ON AT THAT CALIFORNIA
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO INDICATE OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE FULL BUDGET
REQUEST AND THE EP BUDGET
COALITION THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A MODERATOR. NEXT CALL. I WANT TO ONE YOUR
UP. HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME
MARIA STORY AND THE OR
APPARENTLY SOME CISCO BUT I AM
STILL OF THE P. WHO WISHED. USE
VARIOUS CHAU CARE SAID. I WOULD
BE USED CLOTHING BUT PRIORITIES
AND SPECIAL. MINDY BASS CHILD
DELIVER SYSTEM THAT COULD EQUITY
FOR AND PROVIDE. AS A FORMER
PARENT WHO USED BY YOUR SETTINGS
DEPENDING ON THE AGE OF MY CHOI
AND THEIR NEEDS I REALLY BELIEVE
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HONOR THE PROVIDERS ARE ALREADY
DOING IT IN THE COMMUNITY WE
DON'T WANT CORPORATE. GIANTS TO
TAKE OVER OUR PUBLIC FUNDS FOR
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION. AND
ALSO A SUPPORT. AND THE
WEAKENING OF FAMILY PEACE UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY FLOOR- THE LAST
FAMILY CA PAID MOST TRAMADOL.
WHICH WAS WARY MORE THAN- 10%
WAIT THEY COMPANY AT THE TIME MY
KIDS ARE GROWN NOW BUT I'M STILL
ADVOCATING WITH FAMILIES FOR
CHILD CARE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR ATTENTION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR CONTACT MODERATOR
NEXT CALL. FIND TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MARTY EMOTO
FAMILY MEMBER OF A PERSON WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES ALSO
WITH CITY CAN CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY YOU'RE COMING ACTION
NETWORK JUST WANTED THINK- YOU
US SENATOR AND THE COMMITTEE
FOR- YOU KNOW FOCUSING ON THESE
ISSUES ESPECIALLY WITH THE
SENSITIVITY ON THE IMPACT OF THE
YOUNG CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS AND THEIR FAMILIES LASTLY-
JUST WANT TO APPLAUD YOU
CENTERED LAYERED FOR. ALWAYS
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE
EXPLAINED APPRECIATIONS AND
ACRONYMS IT REALLY HELPS MAKE
THE HEARINGS MUCH MORE
ACCESSIBLE SO THANK YOU THANK
YOU AND THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
A RARE MOMENT OF APPLAUSE. OF WE
WERE MOVE TO OUR LAST CALLER-
MODERATOR. AND THAT WILL BE LINE
TWENTY NO TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBERS THIS IS
DONNA HOFFMAN CALLING IN ON
BEHALF OF COUNCIL FOR A STRONG
AMERICA READY NATION FIGHT CRIME
INVESTING KIDS TO MISSION
READINESS. I'M CALLING TO ALIGN
OUR BUDGET REQUEST WITH THOSE OF
THE EASY COALITION AND THE HEAD
START ASSOCIATION AND WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT ANY KIND OF
PRESCHOOL OR TV PROGRAM IT'S
PART OF A MIX OF EVERY SYSTEM
THAT REALLY NEEDS FAMILIES WHERE
THEY ARE AND PROVIDES PARENTAL
CHOICE. THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS
AND MODERATOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR SERVICE TODAY. WE
REALLY APPRECIATED. OF THAT
COMPLETES OUR OUR BUSINESS FOR
THE COMMITTEE AND I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
AND IF YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY FOR IF THE ONE MINUTE
LIMIT TO WAS VERY LIMITING AND
YOU ADD ADDITIONAL THINGS THAT
YOU WANTED TO BRING TO THE
ATTENTION OF THOSE SUBCOMMITTEE-
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING. TO THE
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE THOSE COMMENTS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE INCLUDED IN.
THE OFFICIAL RECORD SO I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION AT
TODAY'S HEARING WE'VE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA WE WILL BACK BE BACK
FOR NINTH AND FINAL HEARING IN
THIS PARTICULAR MARCH TOMORROW
MORNING HERE AT NINE AM. FOR NOW
THE SENATE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE. NUMBER ONE
IS A GERMAN. YEAH.